going to the contender after Freddie
Roach oh really
yeah nice live boom we're live you gonna
wear headphones or no yeah it's better
you where are your cauliflower ears they
keep you from wearing earbuds uh-huh you
know those little feet go in your ear
does I need to it no I don't need it you
don't need it just keep this close to
your face and we're good all right there
we go
what's up man how are you fantastic feel
good I feel good I feel if it would not
be for my like also that I there would
be a I feel better than then I when I
was 25 what did you have your colitis
yeah collide is what is that what causes
that we don't really know what it caused
it but the best the best theory is that
before my last fight with Michael
Bisping I tried to put on weight extra
weight so I followed a diet program that
I was eating every almost every two
hours and I think your system is like a
car you know if you do a lot of mileage
it overuse it and then that's what
happened with the stress and everything
during my training camp a big problem
you know I couldn't sleep at crazy
cramps you know sometimes I had blood
even like when I went to the bathroom at
one point I had to go do some tests
because I was worried that it was
something more like I mean colitis very
serious but that it was I cancer or
something because I had blood so I did
some tests it came out negative and I
said to myself said this fight been
delayed not delayed but postponed so
many time that if I do something if I
say that publicly what is going on I'm
gonna lose the opportunity to fight for
the title yeah at 185 so I I keep it
shot and I told myself said whatever it
is I'll deal with it
after the fight so I did the fight
everything went well then after I went
to do it's called a colonoscopy they put
a camera inside of you yeah and I did I
got diagnosed with also colitis that's
probably the mix of the stress and also
the
fact that I was constantly eating I was
eating and not only eating Joe I was
trying to put on some weight it was very
hard sometimes I was I remember many
time I was having breakfast but I was
really regretting my breakfast I'm
chewing up because you just hidden too
much food yeah but I had to because I
needed to keep my 7 a certain weight and
therefore the crazy thing about it is
first now realize it's a mistake I
should never have done it but when I
made the weight at 185 the day before
the fight I could not go back up to 190
that's a the higher side was going back
up so the day of the fight I I woke up
and I add a little breakfast I drew up
my breakfast again Wow yeah well I was
really messed up then I went to weigh
myself I was like 191 yeah and what do
you think Mike wait he felt very strong
I mean it's not really the weight at
this time because you're the way that
you weigh right now depending what you
eat you have a lot of stuff inside your
your intestine and everything so and
also water retention I felt like I had a
lot of water retention and unnecessary
weight exactly so it's like the other
widest I got back that you carry on your
shoulder so what I should have done I
think is just stay the same way that I
am
my natural weight I think the body has a
way that it's his best way to perform an
athletic performance and that's what I
should have done right but it was a
mistake of my part it was a big mistake
so you were just thinking that because
you're going up to 185 and you're
fighting a guy in Bisping that used to
fight at 205 exactly he's a pretty big
guy exactly that I taught that to
perform better I needed to elevate my
weight but by doing that I created my I
created a big problem of health issues
so and that colitis didn't exist before
that and not that I got diagnosed for no
no and I think that that's what trigger
it and so after the fight now they've
gone back to a normal diet has it
changed so so I've heard a fight what
happened and it's very interesting too I
got in on medication and I I met a
doctor his name is Jason Fong isn't our
motto
people can research his amazing amazing
guy and I met a doctor that treat people
with cancer and diabetes with
intermittent fasting so I started doing
a program of intermittent fasting and
time restricted eating and on my symptom
diminish like every every weeks every
month diminish so he's got it's getting
better it's not 100% now but he's
getting a lot better a lot better and I
feel a lot better we had Ben Greenfield
on yesterday mm-hmm who you know he's a
journalist as a lot of experimenting
with his body not a lot of scientific
stuff and scientific research on diet
and in restricted eating is a big part
of it he does a lot of that it's
interesting because I'm we're a
conditioned to think that I want to when
I gain muscle and when I get you know I
need to eat more to accelerate my
metabolism but but I never felt better
in my life if we would not be for that
particular issue I feel better now I I
sleep better i inflammation and I also
did a test in January I went to McGill
University to do a scan of my my weight
my purse my fat percentage my muscle
density bone density and my in five
month I did it a few days ago like not
not this week the Tuesday of the last
week and my my fat percentage has
decreased my muscle mass has increased
and my weight is at the same hmm then it
wasn't January do you think this is all
from restricted eating my training did
not have change so the only thing has
changed pretty much is the the
restricted restricted time eating and
interpreted fasting yes yeah that
intermittent fasting gives your
digestive system a break and it lets
your body recuperate better I think
that's what helped me uh that mostly I
think it that's what it is a I felt like
I was like okay like I said like a car I
was putting too much for nothing and I
think as human being were over a fad I
I'm very interested about paleontology
and also a history and I know that human
being an ant or gatherer time then that
eat three meals a day no they need eight
maybe a few times a week but when they
eat they eat a lot yes I need to do it
fast so I think it's more natural for a
human being to do so and also I now I
read a lot of stuff and I watch a lot of
stuff on the internet about intermittent
fasting and time restrict the day eating
and I just wish I knew that before for
so many years I I I used to follow the
rules oh we need to eat at least three
time a day and you know I don't really
care of what I eat but I I've you know I
even though in the morning I I was not
hungry I was always my forcing myself to
eat which is bad you know yeah but what
has changed in your diet like what do
you eat like what's what's a normal meal
for you no I don't really I don't really
watch what I eat anymore
I it's more when I eat I try to eat
healthy but I don't have a specific diet
I like for example like Oh Tuesday I'm
gonna eat this this this it's on our
works I just try to eat LT you know like
I I try to eat good and of course I I
don't look at all this is a desert I'm
you know if I want a desert a chocolate
I remember that from one of your old
videos like you were having a glass of
wine during training camp you like
nothing wrong one glass of wine well if
you think about it joy I don't think a
glass of wine or anything let you know
before a fight were some we have the
tendency to be too much like oh what
should i eat what should i do this i
should i do that i think it's and it's a
chance to tense exact met when I went in
Thailand I met some some world champion
Thai boxer and they smoke they get drunk
before the fight I'm like you're
fighting tomorrow man it's like Zygons
like it's no problem but when you think
about it this is an extreme this is to
the other extreme yes but I don't think
it has that much of an effect you know
what I used to eat before like before a
fight my meal of choice before I got
into reading about
eating and stuff like that I was eating
a pasta before before 5:00 most of my
father I eat like fettuccine alfredo I
can that's a lot of carbs I mean it's
not babbling if you eat if you talk to
her for example a nutritionist would be
like oh my god we'll grab his head will
be like you serious oh my - Nikita you
see the steak and pasta before his
fights that was my thing I sweet pass
all the time and there's no problem with
that for me and I felt great but since I
start reading about nutrition and stuff
like that yeah it's like oh you need to
be clean and I'm like they never affect
me I don't think it has that much of a
big big effect you know it's more
psychological I think well it's also you
think about how much energy you're
burning I think for the average person a
bowl of pasta is not a good idea but for
an athlete that's about to fight five
five-minute rounds against a world-class
fighter you have different energy
requirements you know you have different
nutrition requirements you can burn off
way more fuel you know like I was
listening to Chad Mendes on the podcast
the other day and he was talking about
how he's so hungry he eats so much yes -
wakes up in the middle of the night and
he goes and eats sometimes Wow
he just can't he can't go a couple hours
without eating he just has this crazy
metabolism you know what since I
discovered I myristic restricted eating
and intermitted fasting now I feel
better by a training with an empty
stomach
I feel sharper up here mmm I feel more
creative especially in in jiu-jitsu feel
better feel lighter on my feet really
yeah man you do look first you just to
class the morning no no food in your
stomach I never have a food I haven't
eat today this is the coffee you give me
is the first thing I have so when will
you eat it's 12 24 right now after this
I'm gonna I'm gonna go train with
Freddie Roach and then I'm daily and I
and maybe I'll eat another time I'm a
late eater
that's why I'm not too good and I don't
like to eat too much early during the
day yeah I'm not really hungry I used to
eat because everybody eat but now I'm
like I'm not gonna eat since I have I've
discovered this I don't eat when I know
I'm when I'm not hungry and that thing
is why people eat is because they're
spike of insulin you
yeah so when you like when I start doing
intermittent fasting and time restricted
eating it was hard in the beginning
because I was conditioned to eat all the
time
yeah but my buddy acclimate to it and
now it's very easy I can eat once a day
it's no problem
like right now you know I could do it
and I think it's good to be hungry in a
way I remember the doctor who said
something to me said would you rather be
like a lion that just had a full belly
or an angry lion I'm like as a fighter
I'd rather be like an angry lion and it
makes sense to me if you look at nature
it makes sense you know what I mean
it doesn't make sense especially when
you do time restricted eating your your
body gets used to burning off fat - and
using fat as fuel it's true true that's
why I think when I did the test to
compare my my fat percentage diminish
and I didn't have much fat but it
diminished and the doctor I met he says
to him and say yeah I gained a lot of
weight he said you don't you think I'm
gonna lose muscle he says to me he
believed that the way that I put on
because now I'm about 185 pounds and I
when I train for Bisping and went up to
197 when I have to after their way and I
was I couldn't put back that weight up
so I was 190 he believed that the extra
weight that add was more water retention
and residual inside my body
it was not like a solid mass and it
makes sense to me because now I feel
much better and I'm just as strong and
even stronger like when I do Olympic
lifting much stronger gymnastic much
stronger
like I feel sharper yeah and you said it
reduced your information as well it does
have some time elbows you know like
problems yes it was a birthday what's a
birthday that was during my fight of
it's a guavas but I got a get a surgery
to take away the the residual that the
bone chip inside my elbow is not from
landing elbows I think is just use users
use but but now I don't have any problem
anymore
I know what
bill and like it used to be a chronic
thing that I used to fill some once in a
while sometime he came and it goes but
since I started this it didn't came at
all I felt great I can touch my him my
two shoulder like this no you came back
it's very interesting because with a lot
of people they take time off and then
they come back and you wonder what
they're going to look like but one of
the things that I was very hopeful with
you is that you've always been almost a
martial artist first in a fighter second
and in that you're always learning and
you're always practicing like you you
would always take time in between camps
and you would you know do jiu-jitsu in
Brazil or you would be constantly
practicing your muy Thai you're always
trying to learn and improve your game
and I was thinking when you came back it
was like if you were saying that you
were better than ever I'm like man he
might be better than ever like it you
you were the one guy that I believed
because a lot of times guys come back
and like man he's been out of the game a
long time who knows how hard he's been
training because a lot of Fighters when
they're not in camp when they're not
preparing for a fight they don't they
don't like to train that much because
they know the grind of camp
it's almost whereas I'm like you know
how you see a lot of fighters after they
retire they get really fat
yeah like wow how could he get fat like
I was looking at my Donna the other day
is a picture of Madonna's Chino mondop
Maidana
he's got a Instagram page he's fat as
[ __ ] he's got a cigar he's drinking a
whiskey I mean he just fought for him a
with her a couple years ago he was
ripped and this they retired they don't
give a [ __ ] anymore the way I want to do
this anymore but you I knew you were
still training because I would see like
in the hands of Gracie
the guys who were training with you
there and I knew you were training with
Danaher I knew you were constantly
training and you look good so it was
like that when I left off like more than
four years ago III knew I wanted to come
back the guy was not in a nappy place
had a lot of personal problems and I
should have even stopped earlier then
after my fight with Hendrix if if I
would have stopped earlier I would have
maybe come back earlier as well hmm it
was I was I felt like I was like kind of
a filling of a
claustrophobic feeling you know like it
I was I couldn't breathe well I couldn't
sleep well my mind pressure I had too
much pressure personal problems so much
stuff a lot of stuff happened to me that
it's still too early in my life and for
the respect of some people I know I
couldn't talk about it one day I will
all mix together I knew it was a drug
issue in the sport I feel I felt it
added fill well and I was trying to
perform under than those condition and
it was catching up to me yeah and I did
it but the reason why I think I didn't
lose the edge is a lot of people because
we do an extreme sport it's like what we
do is kind of life and death situation
it's not because there's a referee but
the Spirit is the same as a glittery
gladiator or a person in a war that goes
to war he thinks it's gonna die is the
same spirit even though it's not a same
thing we will go there in the same
spirit that we're ready to give it or
give it all it's such an extreme feeling
that once you don't have that in your
life life kind of become boring you feel
like you're not alive anymore so that's
why when people stop they retired and I
try to come back a lot of the people
they fall into drugs because I want to
catch up to that they want to feel alive
again so they want they need that
sensation you know that they had
previously but I couldn't get it back
unless they do drugs or they do
something crazy extravagant the thing
with me is I knew I was going to come
back and also I always like to train and
keep myself in shape and I never did
drugs you know like I never did art
drugs I drink I'm not I drink sometimes
my birthday last Saturday I went out and
I was completely wasted okay it is what
it is I like to date I rate myself
sometime I'm not perfect it's a little
fun exactly and I what's the goal of
doing this if you're not enjoying your
life what's a goal of it right I know
people do fight it's a no I don't like
to fight and that is another thing I'd
like to talk to you about because I why
you do that if you don't like to fight
it's like because I like my lifestyle
you know that it gives me but that's why
people I believe if you come back to
what you say
that's why I think people they have our
time to come back after so many years
because they fall into that trap right
they need to feel alive so then they
find ways to that they in make them feel
alive but it's the it's the Tyrian they
tear your rate themselves yeah
drain idea I didn't do that I did not do
that and I would never will hopefully I
can it's not my thing you know so when
you decided to come back how far out did
you decide like but you you you took
four years off yeah how many years in
were you like I think I'm ready to come
back when I see USA USA DEA and the drug
testing program being implanted and
implemented then I saw a lot of a lot of
late yes a lot of you feel huh like did
you feel vindicated when you saw like
some of these people just I feel a
little bit of a I mean it it feel bad to
wish people bad luck to get some kind of
recognition but that's not what I want I
want to do I don't wish people bad luck
but if you cheat you cheat man and they
a lot of people get cut and finally a
lot of people in the beginning including
my own friend they think like I was
talking some of my own friends they say
oh you're paranoid
you become paranoid you need to take a
break you you're going crazy just retire
get out you know they they you paranoid
because I was talking about it a long
time before Hendricks and they had
everybody was disregarding me but none
when it happened a lot of the champion
fell and a lot of the hero in the sport
they got pointed out with the finger as
AI is a cheater so now it become real so
when I saw that happen it was it was for
me a beginning to start and now it's
time to come back you know because I'm
I'm a guy
if I said something you know that's
become gonna I'm gonna do it I didn't
want to come back when the sport was
dirty that's one of my thing and so when
I when I decided to come back I had a
big talk with one of my trainer John De
Niro and I and for us there's my two
main guy and they're like my friend my
brother with me I mean I'm I'm
undefeated with this with these two guys
you know they're like with
I need them when I fight serious
knowledge yeah those two men and they
mixed together is crazy you know they're
two different person very different they
both have they both studied philosophy
the variant and trusting people for me
to talk with because I have two
different mentalities you know they see
the world at different ways so I like to
have both of their expertise and so John
Johnny told me said listen said you
always have three big criticizing
criticizes when you were fighting this
never went up a weight class you never
you people say that you're kind of
boring you're too much cerebro technique
all you you don't want to take
unnecessary risks which make the fight
boring and also you don't finish your
opponent you know that was one of my big
criticizing criticizes if I decide to
come back and we will change our the way
I was training because the the way you
train reflects the way you fight you
know people say oh I'm gonna I'm not
gonna train too hard I'm gonna do this
and training but when it's time to fight
I'm gonna step up there is no step up
you're just gonna do what what you did
every day you know so I decided to
change a few things and to correct those
three things and that's what happened
you know I'm happy it worked it worked
out well but that was my goal I wanted
to come back for something that excite
me something that was different
something that was unique and rare you
know and I didn't want to come back to
do the same thing I was doing before and
that's why I decided to come back well
when you came back first of all you came
back you fought a very tough guy right
you fought a big Michael Bisping at 185
pounds but what was impressive to me is
like you didn't look like you were gone
like you were like right away you felt
like you felt right back into the groove
again you didn't look at a place he
didn't look uncomfortable and you were
showing things especially different
things with your kicking and your
movement that we hadn't seen from you
before like it looked like you had
improved III was tested and then the
training
even for us some of the guys for us want
to tell them like he whispers to them as
I if you knocked out George inspiring
I'll give you money or you know things
like yeah man is like he's crazy for us
is crazy for us is my war send me in
training sometime you know he tell diet
I tell people is a few if you beat Jay
if you hurt George I'm gonna glorify you
you know I'm gonna we're gonna wow I'm
gonna talk about you and you know way
we're gonna be happy that's the opposite
of what a lot of people think a training
camp should be for a champion it depend
what kind of you know we don't train
like this every day but for my heart
sparring I've when I'm training for a
fight of two days for my last training
camp at two days that it was like hard
sparring that was called we called it
shoot box fight should be shoot bucks
fighting which would put the big loves
the addition pad and his feet to floor
once we touched the floor we stop and we
go back up and that was the area of
expertise were Bisping was the most
competent the the striking Department
he's good at the florist why I I was I
was I was bringing in a lot of good guys
for sparring with me and in that in that
particular training it's hard to find a
someone that is exactly like the guy
you're gonna fight but you can find a
guy that does think better than him in a
particular area you know I cannot find a
replica of Michael Bisping was complete
as much as Michael Bisping but I can
find a guy for example either a guy for
coming from Spain his name is Cesar is a
k1 fighter and he's big guy is like 205
pound and he's big and he's very very
good kickboxer so I had him during my
training camp I flew him from Spain had
a different bunch of guys that I that I
that I was training with and all these
guys that I was training with they are
not like Michael Bisping but in a
certain area that I was training with
them it could be grappling or shoot
shoot box or a different different area
there they could be just as good or
maybe better than Michael Bisping so
that's how I do my training camp yeah
you know I remember when you brought how
do you say his last name is Garbowsky
so John shouts got busky yeah yeah when
you brought him to work with you on the
Ultimate Fighter and he would be
partying all night drunk and show up at
the gym the next day and still [ __ ]
everybody up yeah and did that that guy
influenced you are this your idea about
just be more relaxed in training and
just not worrying about it as much
yeah but he's a different like it's a
total different extreme you know like
like I don't believe in that extreme but
Holly yeah I remember the producer of
the show The Ultimate Fighter when he
was about he was supposed to stay what
week and when he was about to say the
producer was telling me hey can we keep
him for the rest of their show because
it was a good TV you know so I'm like I
don't know I'm gonna ask him and in the
same time like a lot of the people on my
team they were like man okay that's
enough now we got what we need and that
and I was like yeah I like him but he's
kind of a you know I need to kind of
babysit him in the same time yeah the
knowledge that this guy who add and eat
he gave us was just a big big edge you
know and but yeah Charlie's a different
extreme Joe I think there is a a center
line that you need to keep you know
that's what I believe I believe in life
it's not white it's not black it's
always great there's middle zone for
everything I believe ya know I think
you're right about that so when you when
you have a camp and you set up a camp
and you have Donna her and for us
did they essentially are they the
architects of the whole camp do they get
together and try to figure out what
you're doing and when you're doing in
and how is for us the guy who handles
like more of the striking aspects of it
or putting the grappling and striking
together I am a little bit the head guy
in a way you know I believe as a fighter
you need to be the ad guy you're you're
the maestro we'll have the people that
work like with you and and but you need
to know how to use these people good for
instance I I don't know nothing about
business but I have agents that are
there to negotiate Friday
nose number they know about the
investment I have one another guy who
knows about physicality is a is a lawyer
and is good for a tax report I don't
know nothing but I know how to get the
good people to help me for that
particular thing so Farris and Joan for
me are the most competent people that I
can have to help me going to fight
someone because in Joan especially in
the grapping area but John is not only
in grabbing the difference with John and
Farris that makes them very unique as
trainers they're not really only
trainers there are teachers and I would
say the same thing about Freddie Roach
same thing about Freddie Rodin only
trainer they're teachers the way I
structure my my training camp there is
like a pyramid the first layer the fund
that the the the the fundamental the
foundation is physical are you in shape
are you as your vo2 max are you in shape
are you in good condition no injuries
athleticism you're an athlete are you
good good athlete this is a physical
layer this is their the wider one that's
the bottom one it's like a pyramid then
it goes up one layer the technical layer
do you know what to do your knowledge do
you know a number defense to a triangle
choke how to counter a jab or how do you
you know technical aspect you know in
terms of knowledge of fighting that's
where that the trainer comes into play
also the physical the technical and a
lot of that trainer they don't have the
last layer or they only have one of
those or two of those but they don't
have the three layers
that's where feriss John and also I
would say Freddie and boxing comes into
play by an MMA especially for us and
John the tactical layer which is the
last one that's what separate contenders
and champion there's a physical the
technical and the tactical let's say
we're equal we're the same person
what can I make the difference between
me winning against you are you winning
against me the tactical because we're
the same person where I come
bleeped replicas were we're a clone that
the difference is the tactical I will
know how where I can take you out of
your comfort zone and I can bring the
fight where I'm the strongest and and
fight you to element eliminate the odds
were that the fight were will will will
slope the odds of me winning to my
advantage that's where John and Faris
our master at this and Freddie Roach is
master at this unboxing that's why I'm
so I feels very very lucky to have this
guy with me in in my corner because they
they they're competent in these three
layers physical technique technical and
tactical which most trainer can have
only one two or may they not have tree
is very rare to find treat that those
the trainer who can do the these three
thing so when you get to the tactical
layer is this something that you all
agree on they discuss it when we're
approaching a fight like say Michael
Bisping yeah like how do you how do you
do it you say this is what I see in his
fights and then for us gives his input
and John gives his input and then
Freddie gives his input yeah and you
start discussing what's the best way to
handle it so so coming into that fight
with Michael Bisping Michael whisper was
very well prepared was it's very various
as a very good team with Jason perello
so we were expecting you always have to
gauge also to know you and to know your
your opponent you know sometime knowing
you open it is easier than to knowing
yourself you know so you have to be
relaxed realistic about your strengths
and weaknesses and how you're gonna
match up against your opponent with
Michael Bisping what mess mess me up a
little bit is an and all of us is we
were expecting Michael Bisping to come
straight at straight at me try to to
take me out right away instead of that
it was moving especially more in the
second round so the first one was I was
doing well but in the second round start
moving away and be more did instead of
coming at me was more
trying to running away from me and
that's why a lot of people that said to
me as a man that a big because I lost a
second run against Michael Bisping and
people's like man what happened to you
it seems like you were you slow down a
little bit it's only that I saw Donna is
also I yeah I got hit with a very strong
right hand right on the bottom by a guy
who maybe outweigh me but 20 pounds you
know so it slows a man down something
like that my cardio was bad it's not I
was my cardio assignment we get punch on
the bottom it slowed him down and he
caught me off guard he changed his
strategy from round one to round two we
became more like it was more like a
runner instead of a hunter mm-hmm kind
of guy and so he caught you with the
counter shot
what he did is very smart he couldn't
get to me if you look at the replay of
the fight with Michael Bisping you
couldn't get to me straight to my head
was he's trying to hit me with his jab
with his strike tried to target my head
and but I was too fast for him so I
don't know if it's his trainer or him
who decide to change so he decided to be
like like a runner so I decided to try
to chase him a little bit more and what
happened to me he jabbed my my lead hand
which square me and then he connect me
straight on the on that chain well in
the same time I was trying to true a leg
kick
so it was a perfect timing beautiful
execution and I don't know if he
practice that but it was very well done
very smart so I've tried to target my
head II jab my my my hand and hit me
with the the the rear hand and that's
why I hurt me he heard me I try to put
that poker face on and during that fight
he heard me it's one of the strike that
hurt me the most
even though Michael Bisping is not known
as a knockout guy this this this shot
really hurt me because the precision was
the timing was good I've never
understood where people don't think he
hits hard look what he did to Brock hold
yeah he hits [ __ ] hard it's I think
it's what hurt someone in a fight I mean
what can put our way someone is not
necessarily the power by this more
precision and timing and that particular
Ryan was perfectly time and with great
precision so that's why I got hurt and
you win their second round then had to
make adjustment for the third round
that's when for Freddie John and Ferris
come into play there were
what he was doing and they say after the
the ran just slip and come with the hook
over that up and there the right hand
and that's what I did and then knock him
down and and but in in a fight
whatever your trainer tells you if you
didn't practice it it's it's not gonna
work I mean you don't have time to think
it's it's a autopilot yeah so I was on
autopilot sometimes you just need some
some kind of guidance that put you back
your that put your autopilot in the
right direction it that's what happen
into that fight a reminder yes a little
reminder a we're not going this or going
this way our cage then you you then it's
still the autopilot but it's different
direction the crazy thing about Mike is
he
he has very poor vision in his right eye
a lot of people might not know about it
but in the vitor belfort fight he
damaged his retina very badly he said
several surgeries and he's got oil in
his eye that's sort of like protecting
it and he'll have it fixed once he's
done fighting but you know if you look
at him one of his eyes is darker than
the other eyes sure and that's that
right eye and did you particularly
target things going to that right side
like things off of your left side yeah
it's a lot of thing that would drill
done with the left hook that's why like
when I when I hit him with a left hook
that was a lot of times it does but the
thing is with Michael is he adjusts
himself very well to this you know like
like it's like a he knows it and
probably knows that himself or the way
he fights he adjusted very well you know
he put himself in a position that you
cannot get hit often with this you know
especially in my fight so I needed
almost to wait for him to commit with
the right hand to come over the top if
you look at that fight with Kevin gas so
let me the same thing he missed with the
right hand and then he got counter it's
always when he missed with the right
hand that he got count-out can Heartland
fight I think was a mistake it was a
mistake because he was not prepared for
this he didn't write what's also he just
got off of a crazy fight with you it was
bad I think it was a bad mistake for his
part but but look to his credit
he tried to do something and that I do
try to do all the time I tried to do
something unique and very special and if
you would have when we would not have
this description we would have been we
would be saying like man what a comeback
it's unbelievable you lose the title
come back straight to fight Cal Kelvin
Castle what's amazing you know what I
mean he took a risk man and I can't
blame him for that I took a risk myself
too it's just some time you roll the
dice you know when US expect things to
go your way and it didn't go his way
yeah I felt bad but it is with it even
he said that when he came out to that
fight the Kelvin Gaston fight he just
didn't feel like yeah I just didn't feel
there of course it didn't feel there
because he didn't have that time to
prepare for this like I said but you
know you're not gonna go into a fight
and improvise everything you're gonna do
the same thing you've been doing in
training what you've been doing in
training he didn't have enough time to
prepare for that particular type of body
that particular type of like I said
physical technical and tactical which is
the most important one you didn't have
the tech that the tactical preparation
physical was not prep probably a hundred
percent as well and the technical is
there because it's his brain but you
know it's like II didn't program is
autopilot to react to a certain
situation that Kelvin will give him it
was is a lefty shorter stockier you know
different style than me completely
different it's like you couldn't have a
difference mo time or amongst different
style than me then then this guy but he
won the title that way won the title in
11 days notice
I agree it's like work form in the past
it was a way for him in that past but
you didn't get knocked down or choked
out before right oh that messed up your
recuperation
do you know what I mean he was fresh
probably I don't know maybe he wasn't I
don't know personally were what he was
doing but your guys later was it he was
not like him maybe not even a month or
something like yeah it was not you would
not have been cleared to fight if it
would have been in America I don't think
it would have been to clear sight I
think it would not have been to clear it
if I think it was suspended
I think I don't think so because I think
so I think they did because it was in
China is the different it may be the
three weeks Wow
three weeks yeah man you didn't yeah
that seems pretty close yeah yeah
because you heard him with that left
hook and then you choked him unconscious
yeah if it would be me me like maybe I'm
not as courageous as Michael Bisping I
would not not take that fight even me if
I win the fight with Michael Bisping I
would not take that fight I had the word
though courageous pretty courageous guy
is it tactical yeah tactical I I would
not I would not have take that risk
that risk but it's it I'm not in his
shoes I don't know right right his
environment maybe would have you know
toughness is paid off for him though I
mean he's one of the toughest [ __ ]
guys in the sport he always has been and
that toughness is the reason why he's
like [ __ ] it I'll fight again yeah let's
do it
just a [ __ ] animal he's a he's a
great example of hard work and
perseverance and and and you know like
when you say like everything is possible
it is unbelievable is unbelievable
you fighter this guy you know and as
courageous and and what I like about him
to stand for the same thing then I stand
for 4 against performance-enhancing drug
and I think it's very important for me
and then for me was I can honored
fighting him it was like a lot of guy he
lost with this guy that that would have
been cut on performance-enhancing drugs
and and he's very open he talks about it
all the time and then you know it's I
think it's great great model for this
part yeah I know I agree I agree and a
great model for it's just an example of
how you can achieve great things if you
work hard yeah and that's what he's done
he's one of the guy that like I hate him
when I was in training camp but I loved
him as well in the same same time I
remember at one point we're in a
conference in Toronto and the largest
story after the conference we go by the
back kind of the back door of a mall and
there's like a I don't know if it's a it
was staged or not I mean I'm not aware
if it was staged I was not aware of it
so there's a camera like I think it was
TMZ or something it was a camera that
follow us so there is kids following us
- they're about to ask us they asked me
to take pictures and then and then I say
camera coming towards me and then as
Michael that's after the the the cover
is a Michael this system is a don't you
f put your hand on me again because then
and then and then I look in his face and
I I think what as I like you don't put
my NNE quick create kind of a buzz for
the fight and and we start to shout at
each other and the kind of almost pushed
each other and I'm Jason program boys
leave it for the fire boy then then it
so but it's it's not staged it's true
now I'm like and what the hell is doing
there but then after I realize it go it
was on TMZ before I camera right there
then they kids they they who came to ask
me for an autograph they can they came
they kind of get intimidating the right
it's okay it's finish now you can come
and go
thank you when they went back to their
parent I'm not God but it is what it is
you know but that was probably the best
promotion of the old fight like that
particular as an incident you know what
I mean
so I hate him and I love him the same
way Michael is kind of a guy that he's
he's a pro at at boosting the
anticipation for a fight fight you want
to hate him but you kind of love him and
in the same way for the the human being
that he is you know no he's great to
talk and [ __ ] for sure yeah that is a
big thing these days I mean especially
after Connor yeah you know Conor
McGregor has kind of changed the sport
in a lot of ways and that that
shit-talking is a huge factor now it is
but sometimes you don't know when is
really when it's not because I'm not
it's not part of my personality the same
thing at the s ESPN in Boston same thing
we do it interview we go back and for a
black tie that I kind of an almost
insulting each other so to sort of speak
then there you have see does everything
to separate us from one of each other
like I'm like I don't know if it's real
or not I don't even know if he's trying
to push me I gotta push him back because
I feel I felt threatening so you don't
know if it's hype or final
because I'm not an instigator I don't
like confrontation but it is what it is
so I go to the bathroom in between who
comes next the bathroom with with us
it's Michael Bay's like that man is the
camera that photo has said it bathroom
we're taking a piss now next to each
other we're like this then I don't see
Michael base I'm like oh you should then
the camera then you tell a camera to F
out as I get out the never camera goes
out lady look at me look at me then he
start laughing then I start laughing
then I told him I say you got a Range
Rover
he's like yeah but now isn't the garage
I'm not yes you need to get rid of it
because after a while it did start
breaking down as I yeah I know it's like
a game face you later how do you wanna
hate a guy like this you know what I
mean but I hate him
because when we we insulted sure we say
real and salt and real things that we
think about each other but in a in a way
we have the respect yeah so it's really
but so that relationship that I have
with Bisping was very unique I didn't
have the same relationship with Diaz for
example Diaz I don't know we were like
if I meet him even industry today maybe
he hates my guts like I don't know what
he's gonna I don't know if he wanted to
fight me or I got him I really want to
fight you
he's not a hype guy I think I think he
takes it personal I think it's man it's
a freaking spark man is more to life
than what it is because I are fighting
as my Nam and fighting is not my life
man my life is my family man is my
friend the people I love this is what I
do in my life is not my life fighting if
fighting is over it's over or I turn
around do something else you know what I
mean like is what I do in my life some
my life you know what I mean
Sat the end of the world man is more to
life than fighting it's funny hearing
that from you because you would expect
to hear that from someone who isn't
considered one of the greatest of all
time but you're considered one of the
greatest of all time so it would be very
art it would be very hard to argue your
approach because it's been so successful
they they they they they got it baby
super obsessed I'm super obsessed Joe
but that's why I become crazy then I
stop for four years then and when I came
back I some of my circuit and the brain
then I start to analyze myself and like
why I'm why become crazy why did I stop
because I'm taking this stuff too
seriously man you have to take it for
what it is you know yeah it's a world
championship fight I'm fighting I was
fighting Michael miss me after four
years people oh my god the fight are
promoted on drama yeah and like John
said John dinar he says is I fight are
not won on drama r1 or on mundane things
than we do every day
that's how fight r1 yeah how you program
program your your your cruise
your your your cruise driver you know
your your autopilot to win the fight
that's how you you may I see it I fight
like a autopilot you know like so when I
fight when I prepare myself for a fight
especially for the tactical part I
program like a computer ow
I want to react against that specific
problem oh I'm gonna take care that that
specific problem the only way to program
it is to do repetition repetition and
repetition and repetition and repetition
it's like you said one point Eddie Bravo
we said like tie tying tying up your
shoes yes because we've been doing it so
many time you can talk to someone the
same thing yes when I get into a fight
analyze again and I'm fighting and I see
what pattern he does the most often so I
want to program my computer to react to
that pattern that would give me the
advantage into the fight I don't know
when that pattern when occur when I want
to program myself that when it I cure I
have an answer for it right away I don't
have to think about it I don't think I
just react and that's my problem when I
used to fight and I got a lot of
criticizing before I was thinking too
much towards the end of my carer had so
much pressure I didn't perform as well
as I was earlier and especially my last
fight before I stopped for the four
years I was thinking too much over
thinking too putting too much pressure
like you says to say
you have to take it for what it is it's
only a fight in a 10 years you know it's
you know it's sucks if you lose but man
it is what it is you know what I mean
don't take it for don't make it bigger
than what it is it's only a fight and
sometimes it's something very
therapeutic that I like to do before a
fight I Drive a car yeah when I fight in
Vegas for example I Drive a car or New
York same thing I Drive a car when I
used to fight in Vegas back before my
fights I used to be very very stressed
and want a very therapeutic things I
that I like to do is drive my car around
and see normal people then I go and I
thought about I guess mine too why I
Drive and I see old lady with our
grocery store bag ha and I'm thinking
like she doesn't care if I win the fight
Saturday or not she's not even gonna
hear about it then I always another guy
yelling to another guy because whatever
problem or this guy is going to the bank
to pays my is mortgage stuff they don't
care they don't care you know the effect
that I have on the universe is so
freakin small
nobody cares I'm the only one putting
the pressure on me nobody gives a damn
about it so that's why they helped me to
perform now that's how I some younger
gotta say I'm nervous how do you I heard
you don't sleep well that night before I
say yeah it's true I don't sleep well
what is your trick how do you find a way
to sleep well I was like I don't really
sleep well either nowadays it is how do
but how do you feel better about it like
I just know that I'm not gonna sleep
well and it's not gonna affect the
outcome of the competition it's just a
normal thing you learn how to deal with
it better you're not gonna change it
yeah just accept it yeah the stress is
your friend and that's gonna make you
react there's gonna be on the edge have
you ever slept well before a fight never
never only one time which when I fought
Sara and then after that knocked out I
got so scared and it happen again is the
most humiliating day of my career I was
so angry like I said I was like putting
too much on myself it started there
it's like I didn't want go to to buy
eggs at the grocery store because people
this day look get knocked out like I
thought everybody cares about me nobody
cares about you nobody care it's only a
small percentage of population nobody
gives a damn and even if they do what
you make a mistake you you Zig when you
should have zagged you get lip so what
everybody make mistake you have to take
fight like it is you know it's a
sporting event that's why I don't take
it personally like I want to have the
problem with the Diaz but no problem and
is that fight is not personal for me
you're you're in my life now you you
won't be there in ten years maybe maybe
you will my who knows it's only like a
chunk of life that we share together and
then after he's gone no problem with
that it's definitely a better attitude
that's what it is that's how I actually
they should think you know that's that
knowledge that I have is with yours of
yours of competition you know all the
the problem I have the colitis and all
that that's because of that that that BS
that I got it
like putting too much on me if I fight
again it will be it will go back the
same pattern I will I will not be I will
be very stressed and it's normal to be
stress but I will accept it I accept it
better now than I used to do when I was
younger now after you won the title
there was thoughts of whether or not you
would defend it if you were gonna fight
Robert Whittaker yeah like what you were
gonna do what what caused your decision
what made you decide to relinquish the
belt so the reason why I really
encourage that belt is AG I want to do
some physical tests to see what what
what is the problem with my L condition
because doing the the cap I knew I had
problem I didn't know what it was I knew
it was you know that the tests the blood
tests and everything for the cancer
became negative so after I want to do
like like I said colonoscopy it came
back that I had no sir inside my stomach
now as a doctor I say how long it takes
to get rid of this is ice all your life
but there's some term the symptom can go
up down depending every people whatever
they do differently then I started
researching who's the best doctor how
can I do this and that's when I start
reading about
the fasting and stuff and I and then I
then I tried it but I saw that a lot of
you know it in the sport of MMA a lot of
the guys are a starving they they know
they're not hung they're not rich you
know I'm lucky now I have enough money
for the rest of my life I don't need to
fight anymore
you know if I don't do nothing crazy
like buying a private airplane and I'm
not that kind of person or falling into
drugs and stuff like I think I'm good
you know for me my family and everything
and I think I'm good however app when
I'm looking at the landscape I see a lot
of guy like for the pond Connor McGregor
he hold on to the title to do for the
attention the sponsors at this and that
and a lot of people do that that kind
they kind of stole the division and I
said to myself said you know I I stand
for for the fighters always did you know
and publicly as a why am I gonna keep
that idle until to see if I feel better
or not and defend it because I don't
even know if my like my weight was
dropping down like I'm not even a 185
I'm more of 170 or 155 hours I'm not I
don't have the size of a 180 fibers so
I'm like I I I really wish it right away
you know I don't want to install the
division and make people wait because of
me and the world don't go around me you
know what I mean so for the respect I
did I did it when I didn't know before
the fight I was going to did is it
happened like dude you teach it like
this
because I owe ya you know no I know no I
did I didn't know it was going I didn't
know I was going to have a colitis and
all that stuff II it came up I never
tried it before I didn't know what would
be the outcome how I would feel I never
did it you know it was a test and the
same time I'd I didn't know you know I
have a lot of I'm not a perfect man drew
I have a lot of negative stuff about me
my one thing that I'm not is I'm not a
coward this I swear if I say I'm gonna
do something I'm gonna do I'm not a
coward you know and every of my fight
every of my fight I was I'm scared I'm
scared I'm terrified but whatever I feel
I step and I and I I respect my contract
and I do it you know
I didn't know the kaleidos and all that
it was it would be illogical right now
if I want to go back when I'm ready to
go back 185 I'm not 185 you know right
right it would be a stupid move and so
if you're gonna fight again it'll be 170
or 155 yes what where were you leaning
are you leaning towards 55 or 70 I don't
know I I'm Emily I'm gonna I want a lean
word if I I want you know what I've
climbed the Everest many time you know
I've climate once I lose to my used and
I climb it to why I lose then I had then
I got it then I lose to my Sara then I
climb it again and I've done it like
three time and you're light at the end
37 years old I just turned 27 few few
days ago I don't have much left right
for what I have left I want to make the
the big fight the fight that the fan
want to see they want to enjoy I also
want personally for me to achieve
something that is unique that is rare
that maybe it had never been attempted
before you know that would be something
that excite me and I'm not only driven
by money you know I like like a I got
it's good to have money you like money
it drives us all including myself but
it's not the unique thing that drives me
you need to be more than money and they
need to be some kind of achievement
think that comes with it that would
exciting me so would that be there would
be a hundred fifty five billion Tyler
they are they they are for me Nate Diaz
now yeah and and and it was a it was a
rumor they say it was a done deal it's
not a done deal not on my part and I
don't think it was on Nate Diaz part as
well because from what I've heard his
brother Nick's and even Nate says that's
his big brothers fight it's not his
fight from Nick Nate Diaz they the
incredible fighter very well-rounded
however from if you put yourself in my
shoes there is nothing good that can
come out of it except
money and money is not the only thing
that really drive me if I beatnik the
Nate Diaz decisively some people will
say I'm almost because they are he took
an easy fight or whatever like the
criticizing will say to say oh he is a
bully
you know 155 yeah he fought a smaller
guy that can be the smaller maybe it's
not even smaller than me maybe we're
about the most 51 a lot of 155 little
guys are bigger than me right now it's
big he's a big guy he's about the same
size of me but because I compete at 170
for most of my career and you won the
title yes it will make me look bad it
will make me look like a bully and this
is if I win decisively if I for example
if I win not decisively if I wouldn't
act it's a war back and forth at
people's I suck you cannot even you know
what I mean yeah and if I get beat oh my
god forget it this formerly guess is the
end of the world all the work I put in
is finished and I could have a bad day
yeah something that I discovered too
during my career is being the strongest
man in the world that's my that was my
dream when I was young that's why I did
UFC I wanted to be the stronger man in
the world and I realize over there this
it did not exist you cannot be the
stronger man in the world this is an
illusion I love the younger guy deserve
the best man now you're not man it
doesn't exist you would be strong you
would be a better fighter than this guy
in that particular day at that
particular location at that particular
moment maybe in an hour if the fight
would occur an hour later an hour before
or maybe in a different place where they
the altitude desire or lower or
different scenario different environment
you will lose that fight it's always a
question of odds you know what I mean so
being a stronger man in the world it
does its style makes fight maybe we were
three guys I beat you you beat em he
beat me who's who's the best guy
there's no best guy right that's MMA
math right it is it is that's the way to
see it so there is no stronger man in
the world you can't you say oh I'm the
baddest man on the planet because I'm
champion like the belt thing is an
illusion the belt thing belt thing is a
symbol but it's an illusion it doesn't
exist you're not the stronger man and
the
I know a lot of people will disagree
with me but is it is what is that
if you ask most experienced fighter most
people will think the same way because
we realized on one point like when we're
young because of our confident or maybe
there are the cockiness or or a
confidence after it not that it fades
but we we see we have more experience
with knowledge we rise it's all it's all
bs it's not true
so the UFC offered you Nate the did you
consider it at all or was it like I
consider it
I consider it however I analyze it I
talked with feras with my trainer and
everybody we were all on the same page
on that it's like it's no it's not it's
not worth it but did UFC announced it
did they said that they were working on
I think I think they an out said I'm not
sure I I think they said it was a done
deal
look it's not the first time it happened
and yeah and I'm not they have a
business to run the UFC and they're
their biggest fear is someone take the
title and run with it and it's been I've
been doing it two times with Johnny and
tricks and with Michael Bisping like I
run they say I run but is for the
reasons you know there's always a reason
and and that's their biggest fear sure
so that and understand that they have a
business to run it's but it's it's like
WWE when did the giant pass the torch to
all Cogan he passed the torch because
it's for the business and he agreed to
pass the torch yes but a thing in this
in this in this part we're not and WWE
it's my life on the line here yes I
don't care about the business I do what
is the best for my interest to me sure
you have to I have to have to be selfish
and I am selfish I say it openly I am I
say it to the fan to every I am selfish
because it's a it's a sport that I can
die man you can die in this part and
this is the truth can get or not maybe
not that but it could create create at
your death in the next time to come in
the next year maybe you get that blow
that messed up something in your brain
because of a trauma that creates
something else
so it's a very serious sport man it's
not like a you play Aki play baseball
play football you don't play fighting so
you do it for yourself you do what is
best for yourself the organization will
do what is best for the organization
they're not your friend
right so that's why the relation have
with Dana and some of the guy in UFC
it's a very special relationship maybe
one day we'll sit down I will talk about
the good ol day then and have a blast
have a laugh well right now we I always
am always on the defensive when my phone
ring I see that no way like God then I
say what I should say what I should not
say nananana and I'm completely honest
about it it's like some pie dresser no I
say if you do that's because you're an
idiot if you do that if you just take
any fight that you yeah yeah no I mean
it doesn't work like that
it's the Ascension to be champion is not
a straight line is this always an
obstacle there you know then you come
back there is it it is what it is it is
what it is and you need to be surround
by smart people and if you don't have
smart people you need to be smart enough
to find those people that are competent
that will help you in particular domain
that you're not competent to make the
job for you and complete your circle you
know yeah Dana was saying for a while
that you didn't want to fight he was
saying George does want to fight he said
before I don't want to fight before I
fought Bisping you know he said that
laughs why do you think you were saying
that do you think he was putting
pressure on you psychologically I was
[ __ ] with your head yes I'm so my ego
would let me okay I'll show you that I
can fight bring me this guy it's a
freaking game it's all a game we say
it's not a game it's really on it's all
a game it's all business it's all a game
I like Dana Dana man the sport was
nowhere yeah the sport was gone mate
didn't go nowhere because of Dana
WeHo Dana my living I hope it to Dana
White when I do the UFC Wayans when I
introduce everybody I point to him I say
Dana White without him none of this
would be possible and you write a
hundred percent hundred percent is the
best pound-for-pound promoter of all
time I don't care about dunking whoever
you
Dana White is the best it's better than
all sport included I never seen anything
like this he can sell ice to an Eskimo
if you want to is incredibly great fun
and he's good at messing up with my head
too because even though I try sometimes
my ego is like like natan ideas because
the stuff is said to in the way they try
I don't know if the UFC tried to make
him say stuff because some fighters are
more like pawned on a chest on a check
chessboard and others
me I'm not I don't follow in everything
analyzed I'm thinking I was like why you
say that why
ok that's bigger so a lot of stuff have
been said in my ego something like yeah
what and I want to say all right you
think my smash schedule is too busy I'll
take therefore it or not you know what I
mean but I should not do that this as
stupid move if I start acting like this
I'm broom yeah and a lot of guy they
don't have that self control and self
discipline in them hmm
it's all a game man that's all a game
it's not it's all it's BS it's all a
game man it's all a game what didn't
they'd say the [ __ ] with you ok lazy
ass and Nick is like kind of together in
a way they say that I took steroid when
I fought his brother I messed up my
glove my rap I didn't make weight and
what did he say oh yeah I put something
in that in the IV of his brother so he
said if I want to take care of that like
if I don't know he said it in his own
like word like in English slang like oh
yeah if you want to take care of this
I'm there you know he said someone
poisoned him yes who was was that for
which fight was that that Anderson's
over ok I gotta confess to June I gotta
confess I gotta confess okay I was I was
so scared doing this this fight so we
tried to poison I was so scared of
fighting Nick Diaz or with poison his IV
but he survived so I was even more
terrified
you know so all the athletic commission
was on my prayer role so they trade away
and then I made it
and it went true so I was even more
terrified so the alien abduct me and
what I got they put the gamma ray to
increase my strength like the oak like a
performance-enhancing drug and the fight
was still happening so right before I
put some glass and cement in my gloves
make sure and still add a crazy hard
fight you know so I gotta confess with
my mouth but it's completely insane you
know your fight
you said all that is he said for my
fight that III pause on his IV that I
was on steroid that I my my my rap was
wrong and and he said also what he said
that he said yeah the the the way and
like I didn't make weight like I tricked
the Athletic Commission or they were on
my like so like it's it's just funny
it's I think he has a he has a problem
of conspiration conspiration you think
everybody's against him you know
paranoia yes I think that's what it is
that might be the weed it could be you
know I say nothing bad about a weed but
we'd like all things can be good but
also can be but yeah I know you're for
the weight itself I will enjoy wheat and
you're a smart guy you have much better
argument and at that in are sensible use
though of everything including drinking
yeah I like a drink every now and then
but like I like pot yeah I don't think
you should smoke it all day yeah but I
think that's what it is I think weed
I don't know if it's a weed but I think
it's maybe weed with social environment
or or and genetic can create some kind
of disorder disorder in in the brain and
make you have the conspiration
conspiracy problem you think everybody's
against you is good happen and it could
happen I've seen a lot of my friend who
smoke a lot they have this problem yeah
sometime they think they can't date a
paranoid mm-hmm yeah I think it's like
all things you do too much of it it can
[ __ ] with your head everything could be
good or bad
yeah now you use it so what fight is
interesting to you there's this talk of
khabib at 1:55 is the champion now yes
and Conor those are the two fights in
right here right right now right now as
we speak now
I wouldn't want not want right now to
put myself immediately in a training
camp because the reason is my symptom is
not gonna ice your colitis I feel a
little bit it's not it's it's not as bad
as it was not even close
it's much better but I want to get the
rear of it before I get into a training
camp you know before I get put myself
into a stress because that stress what
it doesn't amplify everything so if you
have likes little issues that it will
amplify it yeah and at least I need to
take care that my my LT is an pass in
front of my performance and support this
very important and when I'm ready like I
don't know I made I would like do
something like I said unique rear
something that is reared I've never been
done before
that would be a 55-pound champ it could
be 55 which is the first and I'm in a
moment while the tree title never been
done before
or it could be maybe by that time it
would be another guy maybe I don't know
it would be someone will come back and
do something great that you will be the
man to beat you know I mean we talked
about the Diaz brother and an outsider
change subject a little bit but with on
the same way it's sad for for Nick Diaz
that he doesn't fight yeah because
stylistically before might think I'm
crazy but stylistically I think he can
beat tyron woodley I think he can is the
kind of guy I keep coming at you keep
coming at you and take is good at taking
shots surviving that keep coming keep
coming at you and I remember when I
fought him it's terrifying because you
got tired and this guy keep coming at
you and he make you feel like you
claustrophobic and you you do things at
him and he keep coming and he's very
natural and then layer around like after
like three four around and like man it's
like it's very he never gets tired it
doesn't get her but it it it's it makes
you it's exhausting
you're so nervous on the nervous system
and
and the mental system not only
physically sound numb not much
physically it's it's on the nervous
system he'd come at you and you fake and
then and and there was like a reaction
time and reset time when you fight you
know like like and I I've studied this
with my team when I was fighting guys
and the ideas he make people tired he
make the nickk nickk nickk that's why he
wins fight he's kind of a slow guy but
but people get more tired than him
quickly especially in their nervous
system yeah there is guy like BJ Penn
for example when I fought with Japan I
knew that BJ Penn had the best reaction
time of all fighter we have seen in UFC
when he was I did at his best I measure
the guy I we know were as measure with
with the frame you know i frame like a
picture when you throw a punch big
click-click
BJ Penn had the best reaction time of
all fighters BJ Penn when he was in his
best and when I fought him I knew if I
go straight at him you have a better
reaction time then than me so my goal he
had a very good reaction time but a bad
reset time so his visa time is kind of
the entrance for the brain so you could
react yeah I can smell you could react
very fast but after a while he got tired
very very fast after a lot of faking it
and then this I make him guess and stuff
she was getting very tired fast so
because of that I could get him because
of that I could I could fake him and
make him tired and lower his reaction
time and then get him later
yeah so Nate Diaz that's why he's so
good and they dick [ __ ] yeah sorry
that's always so good and then that's
sad for him and he doesn't fight it's
yours are his best years are now it
should do now that's what you should do
man he's only 33 is that what we said 33
or 34 mean he's in it yeah you should do
it now he should do it man he had an
important thing make a lot money but you
could do it I could he could do it they
suspended him for pot after he fought
Anderson Silva and then he had to pay a
fine they never paid the fly because
he's Nick Diaz is it no but I respect
that because in his mind he think is
wrong and he don't you know he has a
line you have a code you know yeah and
the same thing I have the code for me
for the drug test policy I didn't want
to
back unless they do something I say it
to Lorenzo and Dana after my fight with
my last fight I say it is in my code and
I they wouldn't have done it I would not
have come back I've never seen Hendrix
was on something this is a question I
don't have the evidence I would never
have like you don't have the evidence
that we talk about fighters like I like
that got cut you know what have the
evidence they were there before they got
cut like why not have the evidence the
only thing I can say is I didn't want to
attack one particular individual and I
wanted to change the system because if
you attack one individual another one
will come so in that particular case was
Hendrix and I wanted to change it and in
the beginning he agreed with me to do it
but then he changed his mind and that's
when I got very young so he agreed with
you to take we agreed I agreed it was
public he agreed when we say it you can
look you have the evidence that in the
interview he said I agreed to do a test
but then he said no I did not agree
because also the UFC told him to not
agree the UFC told him do you know the
UFC told him is the truth they told him
to not do it because I there were they
didn't want he had a problem may be with
the the vada the the avada world in
title yes yes that there is what whether
that make the guideline but they're fat
that's valid that I took it they had a
problem with them I don't know why it
was actor Conti did you know it was Mary
Margaret Margaret something or it was a
lady but they had a problem so they said
to not do with the deaths may not do it
period I don't know if it was big I
think it was because I Vader because I
made a little investigation on that and
I got very angry that's why like
psychologically I said to myself I
shouldn't I should not have if I would
have go back in time enough I would not
have take that that fight hmm I'm gonna
have to take that fight that's why I
respect a lot fighter they stand up for
themselves I didn't have the courage
that I didn't do it when it was time to
do it and I sure that I regret it about
this is one thing I regret in my career
I should have done it so you don't wanna
sighing okay take your belt I'm going
yeah I should have done that before
maybe I would have come back earlier hmm
so I would miss a paycheck but wouldn't
who you know I had enough I would have
enough you know what I mean
so you don't want to say whether or not
you suspect that Johnny Hendrix was
doing something but there was people
that were definitely doing something yes
and I don't have the evidence maybe he
did maybe look I don't want IQs and a
lot of guys they do it and I don't I
don't want to judge them because I love
that they have a family to feed and
everything and this could make the
difference between winning a million
dollar or not winning like at all you
know what I mean
so everybody has a different reason why
they do it and I and it's just a system
encourage it yeah to do it that's a
problem yeah and especially if there's
no testing or if the testing is very
poor yes like the testing when you first
started your career
I mean basically just had a pee after
the weigh-in and you were okay you have
to be even now it's still easy to even
now it's you think so yeah like how
would someone rigged this okay now okay
let's say I have a we're about in my
phone okay now I'm saying it and
everybody knows that especially the
cheater they know that look I've done I
thought it true it's not a hundred
percent sure but let's say I want to
have an injection of a product that will
last in my body for two days or one day
so I know that particular day I cannot
be tested because if I am I'm screwed
right so I put an I put my on them I
worry about that I'm traveling to the
freakin Antarctica or anywhere like
somewhere that is crazy livable yeah and
then I come back in two two days after
but that substance will send my body for
a certain period of time but it will the
effect of it will last maybe a month
yeah and now we talk about performance
enhancing drugs Joe people a
misunderstanding sir oh yeah but it
still doesn't make different yes it does
make the difference in an athlete and
the reason is in the 80s and before it
was giving you more power more stamina
more enjoyments now
with the technology they have stuff that
will change your reaction time your
confidence your reset time and now this
is a huge huge application man if you're
if you play baseball or you're in
fighting you see the things coming
you have your reaction time you're
sharper in that brain what makes a guy
athletic it's not as muscle the reason
why Usain Bolt is you run faster there's
many reason why but one of the main
reason is because his brain is nervous
system is better and if you make your
nervous system better and more competent
it better
you're a better athlete man you better
fighter you better baseball very better
than you better purse better person in a
way of course that effect is limited but
there's still depth of muscle memory
everything that will last you know when
you could live forever so now with the
technology man I want point the sport
that's why I'm afraid I'm afraid the
sport becomes so messed up that with the
gene doping you know that at one point
it would be off sport will be completely
completely messed up in the future at
all not know but sport will be it won't
be any normal people competing will be
all like kind of a Seaborg people yeah
cyborgs everybody people are really
worried about gene doping and yeah man
they're already starting to do that
minority gene even the mother the mother
and stuff performance-enhancing drug
they do man it's very hard to catch up
people so like I said it's easy to take
something I mean there is always that
chance that you get caught but that's
how I if I would do it that's how we do
you know would pretend I'm going in art
Antartica I get an injection then I come
back and I'm I'm good Nowitzki told me
that they're starting will they they
have it and they don't know whether or
not people are taking it but they're
taking testosterones is derived from
animals not from wild yams like the way
they get testosterone now if you get
like a testosterone injection they're
getting it from wild yams and some yams
yeah the fruit other the you know the
vegetable really the tuber you know in
Jamaica is them yeah yeah that's how
they're getting testosterone they're
getting it from that yeah
well yeah yeah the plant-based wild yam
testosterone but now they're able to get
it from animals and the animal
testosterone you you don't like they do
carbon isotope tests yes and the carbon
isotope tests don't detect the
difference between a animal testosterone
and human testosterone but these are
current tests one of the things that
they do is they freeze your piss and
they freeze your blood for and they're
doing it for years and this is how
they've caught some of these Russian
wrestlers and they've taken away gold
medals from guys that won in the early
2000s who for they've found new tests
and with the new tests they were able to
determine that they were taking steroid
thing is that same thing when Ben
Johnson beat Carl Lewis yes yeah and Ben
Johnson is well he was on some [ __ ] but
guess what Carl day there was no [ __ ]
yeah then I think nine out of the ten or
eight out of that like the guy that that
finished like eight like it was a
Brazilian guy but then he entered he got
interviews idea I was just a line
fillers for the main guy he would have
won the gold medal right because man
that should change your life that
changed your life man you make you a
better living millionaire maybe
sponsorship yeah that's just so bad you
know is he yeah man is crazy about Lance
Armstrong yeah when you go the Tour de
France when he won and then they took
his title away all the people that were
below him were also guilty yeah so you
take his title away who would about the
number two he's [ __ ] guilty to number
three they said that on one of the years
and he won you had to go back to 18th
place to find a guy who's never caught
taking anything that's a dirty sport but
man you asked me if I think he was
taking I don't know I have suspicions I
have a suspicion but it's not right if
you know what have the evidence like you
someone yes I agree man even today it's
if I think there is some guys if there
is a lot of guy that takes the red and
performance-enhancing drug yes yes and I
have an idea of who who and I'm pretty
like just for my gut feeling 99.9
percent sure
but I don't have the evidence it's not
what you think
right it's somewhat you know is what you
can prove and ice I don't know you know
talking you know I'm in a game I'm
talking to a lot of people in between
fighters we know who does who there's
only a few and full of people who does
the whole the whole team you know you
know one guy could do these team this
team this team and one other guy can do
two team the word go it goes around man
especially when you're your top elite
fighter world goes the world goes around
you know like the people they they talk
to me and they say if I would be
interested enough different offered
before in different things you know what
have you been offered before I've been
offered meant to sometime to go train
and then like some deals you know that
good go train and do do something being
been part of you know like they have a
they take sample of your blood they know
what is missing then they put the stuff
that is missing make you as I know as I
read a stay in Montreal you know like I
okay and I don't say much much all could
it could be a lot of cheat or to like I
died that's the thing you accuse a gym
of cheating you cannot accuse a gem of
cheating because everybody is different
you know there's people cheating
everywhere now you can't say oh these
these people are chit Nam and it doesn't
work like that
it works every individual you know if
you made the choice if you decide to go
that path you have to be ready to face
the consequence if you don't face a
consequence during your your competition
yours maybe you'll face later after you
you gone and you retire for your careers
I a lot of a lot of people I know he's
quitting a lot some of my friend they
were bodybuilders now you should see
their body are messed up man yeah
they're hormones are all messed up did
they did they got bad problem I don't
want to be like that yeah I don't want
to be like that I want to be happy you
know what to be healthy
yeah they tear the joint apart to that's
all I had Dorian Yates on the podcast he
can't even do push-ups now I mean and
Dorian Yates was mr. Olympia was a
[ __ ] giant guy but all that
everything just ripped apart it's like
everything he's all [ __ ] up it just
doesn't work right anymore however if
you ask these people would you do it
again maybe they say yeah maybe it was
it maybe was worth it maybe it wasn't
make it depend of every individual you
know one me but for me yeah I'm happy
with what I have so far though I could
get more maybe the future but I don't
want to do to go that path to try to
risk everything or whatever I think when
testosterone replacement therapy was a
thing and they were allowing people like
Vitor and these people to take
testosterone I was so frickin angry
about this I think it was like you know
everybody it's a different case for
everybody but I believe if you if you
need to take the medication to compete
performance and a medication to compete
you should not be allowed should be and
Joe I'm not against a roid I'm gonna
explain to like people so is again I'm
not against per like steroid or I'm not
against it if it's for the well-being if
it's an older man who we cannot have sex
with his wife and he is like man he goes
to the doctors like man I I lose the
edge a little bit
can we director was that yeah I put the
cream that that will increase it a sound
so you and the guy is a pure you have
sex with his rival competition yes in
terms of competition if me and you were
fighting and I we sign that we're not
using any weapon and I'm talking about
biological weapon and we fight man to
man as real martial artists by a code of
a code of honor a new behind or me I go
and inject myself something to make me
stronger or more competent my may could
also help my neurone to further fire
better to get something to be more or to
be better to enhance my performance now
and now I'm against that yeah there's a
code of honor and if you don't respect
that code man it should be out of
martial art what are people taking that
makes the reaction time better it makes
her mind I don't know that the name but
there there is many if you talk to a guy
that there's a lot of things a lot of
thing I know is baseball player they
take stuff for the reaction time like
the pitch heard and this because in
baseball in tennis and even in fighting
before you try a punch there is like an
indication yeah but the body language
you read something like before you try
ball there's a movement for you punch
there's a so you see better you run
you brain there's even a medication you
can take for exam you study in school
there's an exam - you have an exam
tomorrow we're gonna study your your the
stuff that you need to know then and I
will increase you then you go pass the
exam I know it sound crazy go go go get
it in this crazy man
why no adderall Annerose want it makes
you guys manly make you bad better in
the brain if you make your brain better
your nervous system better man you but
you you're better fighter yeah it's not
only physic physical enhancement it
wasn't the 80s now in the 2000 year now
now it's neurologic man that's when it's
it's crazy dangerous and soon it will be
like it with the gene doping forget it
man the athlete will be born athlete you
want me I got like me or anybody that
fight in UFC won't be able to compete
and you have seen anymore because they
are not super you mean human you know
what I mean no I agree the future sport
will be so messed up it will be crazy
we're all gonna be gamers play video
game yeah right yeah you're probably
right
we're all gonna be gamers this this will
be end with this thing that like being
an athlete
will it's not it's not gonna make any
sense in the future I believe you know
maybe we'll be completely ridiculous say
oh you're not born you're never gonna be
yeah no you know I mean and it will be
real because you're not born to be a now
you're not bred to be an athlete yeah
they would with gene editing they're
they're going to be able to change your
height they're going they can do it now
they can do it now they haven't really
shown that they can do it with humans in
America at least crazy but they're
absolutely experiencing experimenting
with it all the world the cow and ever
like it's insane it's insane
they're doing a lot of crazy [ __ ] yeah
and I think maybe it's a hundred years
maybe it's 50 years but whatever it is
in that amount of time you're going to
be dealing with people that are
basically superheroes yeah the sport
will be destroyed
that's what when when that happen sport
will be destroyed yeah no I agree the
sport will be finished and like the 100
meter can you believe like ow freaking
fast a human being can be to be closer
to zero second yeah
like do you think we'll pass the the bar
of nine second one day it's there
theoretically not impossible in a way
I mean I won't point there there's a
line that you can't like you know you
can diminish that time but it's like a
Charles you know like you can't you know
but if we get that sort of performance
enhancing drug that's would be but there
would be some sort of a side effect to
it and some sort of a downside to it you
know there probably die younger there
tissue diminish faster but who knows
that maybe they'll be able to regenerate
stuff if you talk to some doctor that
knows like I know you have done they
said that steroid like
performance-enhancing drug if you do it
if they do it well it's okay some people
don't have any side effect of it right
they don't abuse it yes yeah so man
maybe it won't have any side effect
maybe everybody will be on it maybe it
will be like like an iPhone will be like
oh that's like who knows who knows the
future who knows you know that's totally
possible I mean we you might be in a lot
of ways one of the last of the natural
athletes maybe maybe it's a few more
years before we get there but yeah man
it when I think about it is gonna be
it's gonna be finished it's gonna be I
don't know maybe will gonna be video
game players or whatever when you see
yourself competing again how much longer
do you think you weighed out I mean
you're 37 now when do you think you'll
will be healthy enough when will your
colitis feel good enough like do you
have a time period to say baby few weeks
maybe it'd take a few weeks maybe one to
three month max maybe maximum maybe less
than that maybe less than that a little
bit of time off just a little bit yeah
yeah yeah I want to make sure I get past
that because I feel like if I go back
into it and I and it will start all over
again
I don't want that it was bad Joe I could
like I couldn't sleep night I had like
crap like bad crap mega I stay up all
night and add the sparing the next day
and yeah oh my god it was crazy man it's
very bad he had blood I had to go in the
back way I had blood man you feel like
you you want to go to bathroom but then
and I think ammidon is the blood the
blood that come out man you could look
at the bathroom you see the blood you
think it's like man what's wrong you
think you like them the the the
dreamcatcher the movie with
yeah you know what I mean likes like
what the hell you know what I yeah it's
crazy man you like you like what's
happening with me am i dying is I is it
was very it was very I don't want to go
back to this I want to make sure I take
care of this stuff you know so just
maybe even a few more months of just
taking care of your body month week week
I want one I want to see when I feel
good I a little let a little bit time
when I feel like a hundred percent like
I don't feel anything
like sometimes I feel like when I gotta
eat I feel I feel not that crime not
that pain but I I feel inside is
something different right but it is them
it diminish every every week it's every
month it diminish I see a difference so
if you do go back and you'd go back to
55 have you tried to make that cut
before I never tried and I won't when I
explained to you I'm not a fan of weight
cutting I think weight cutting should be
like a marathon runner a marathon runner
when you train for my right and he never
does a marathon in this training he does
F or maybe a quarter of it at different
things so it's not LT to lose your
weight right you dehydrate yourself and
starving is not that bad but it's more
than the hydrated reiteration problem me
I'm very worried about health issue and
I don't want this very important so when
I do it I go all in I'll do like the
best ping fight I never tried to do to
get my weight much it's different you
know when you go up and go down but
right I said yes I do it and I go and I
you know what I mean and I do it do you
I like that trail of it the excitement
of the unknown well you kind of excite
me in a way I don't know if you know so
it's kind of an experimentation it's
live I cannot messed up right that's
what excite me it's not the oh I know I
can't know I don't know man I'm gonna do
it now it's happening now that's that's
what excite me well this guys are the
your size like heavenly is your size you
know he never needs about my size I
think khabib is about I think close to
200 I saw a different Ferguson is that
you II was a posting picture he was 200
I never been naturally 200 like like
when I fought best bang at one point I
was almost 200 like I was like
big guy like but I was like all like
water-retention I didn't feel I didn't
feel right it was not feeling good man
yeah kevin is a big guy and there was an
article today I saw somewhere that was
saying you know the Kevin really wants a
165 pound weight class like you can't
really make 155 very much longer I think
it would be the best man this guy I
think if I look all the new guy that are
coming it's freaking scary man I'm 37
maybe I have one maybe what two maybe
three I don't know what like I do my
thing and I get out of there what do you
think you're gonna retire do you have an
idea
oh I never got 40 you've it's impossible
that I fight past 40 I'll be impossible
damn again I'm not gonna fight in a cage
at 4 years old and like 37 man is like
it's like I killed that play like that's
our North was a [ __ ] what he says to
me is like I killed that play with that
train he's two years old three years old
four years old five years old then you
look at that train when you get six
years I like the hell I'm doing with
that train at 40 years old is finished
for me fighting in a cage are you I've
done it like it's not interesting here
now 40 years old am I mean I'm a grown
man I'm not gonna fight in a freakin
cage at 40 years old
that's only thirty six months from now
you say it saying it like it ever yeah
exactly so it has to happen fast that's
a fact and if it don't happen I'm happy
I'm happy too well to come back alone
was like one of the greatest comebacks
ever yeah come back after four years win
the title beat the champion and beat him
to finish definitively rear naked choke
put him to sleep that that's why I draw
it need to be something that really
excite me because I'm gonna tell you
something I
one of my friends Ct Fletcher he says
something about Ct Fletcher that is a
heart transplant yeah he's doing good
now he said I love to CT CT you're the
inspiration and see the your inspiration
man I love that guy he says satisfaction
is the def def blue and it's true now
I'm happy I'm satisfied but if I see
something on satisfaction is def Blue is
finish if you're satisfied if you're a
champion in your satisfy retirement
because you going down
you finish
gonna get hurt yeah as an athlete
especially in our game
nah man and everything I do I go further
and further that's why I didn't want to
fight Nate Diaz
I have AI fighting Nate Diaz it's been
done before it's been it's not excite
excited for me and I would be going into
that fight satisfy and if I could do
that I'm gonna it's very dangerous I
want to do something that I'm like like
the 155 I'm like I never did it before
title or beating a certain guy that he's
on a freakin rise and we could beat them
because like a big a baby's already
beaten Connor
Kabhi Kabhi it could be I don't know is
if their new guy that do something like
that is unbeatable
I mean I come back I'm like Oh George
never gonna be dead we say never man I
love it they say never when Dana
squeezer it is when he said never gonna
come back and I like it excite me and
when you say I cannot do that it's never
been done before that's mean if I do it
it would be the first time that excite
me I really turned me on as but there's
a lot of theater me on in life is a
woman dinosaurs and this they're people
that say don't that really may be going
crazy dinosaurs yeah no it's
paleontology that's awesome I traveled
the world during those four years off by
the way that did you yeah what did you
do during those four years off I was
very I went I travel a lot of the world
on the site and sightseeing yeah yeah I
would never be that that made me realize
too that I could never be a
paleontologist I don't have the patience
to go like a will to brush for hours I'm
driving I like to get the knowledge of
it to be on the field to get the
knowledge fast right but I don't like to
work together knowledge right which
which make me not a real paleontologist
the final intelligence is willing to put
the work into it yeah in MMA I'm willing
to put the work into it to become the
champion you know yeah but in
paleontology that's how I because I'm a
point I thought I like both equally now
I realize no I like the sport better
problem the sport of MMA is so exciting
and paleontology is probably very
exciting
she find like a t-rex head or something
like that isn't a knowledge man it's
very knowledge is exciting I said every
I have a thing in every month every time
the other discoveries it's in my phone
yes every time is new discovery or
something like poem and my friend I make
fun of me like bad you be the people you
like paleontology was wrong because they
make fun of me I went in Argentina in in
Patagonia I was there too with like
Polly autologous bio biologists and
microbiologist - on site you know and I
had that blast man it was amazing but
people's eye choice is gone in a
freaking bad land and I'm like alone
isolated for the rest of the world - you
know so they were making fun did you
find anything I did not find it but I
went on site I so eggs
I saw sauropod remains titanosaurs there
these are they're still in the ground
when you were there yeah yeah but jus it
takes it's a long process man this
that's mean it has been covered for at
least like 66 million years man you talk
about light and the place where I was
was it was early the Cretaceous and I
was like Cretaceous but it was like a
hundred million years so that's mean it
did not get exposed to oxygen for 100
million years that's way again so you
you it's like a crime scene man we go
and this thing you it's freaking there
man it's like a crime scene that you
discover but like a like a hundred
million years crime scene and you see
these sauropods meant these titanosaurs
it's insane man what's crazy to that
it's not even really a bone anymore the
mineral has replaced the bone and you
just get the shape of the bone that sort
of been fossilized yeah you know like
that's why if you see like Megalodon
teeth they're black I haven't my house
the Megalodon teeth it's insane man
Megalodon is like the strongest bite
force ever recorded man it's crazy big
[ __ ] a yeah there's a huge fish yeah
you should feed on whales like yeah
it's crazy but like this is one of the
things I really excited me so during
those four years I was doing man I had a
blast I didn't have that time to do it
before that and I felt like it was
missing in my life
real paleontologists yeah yeah that's
fast now I went at Alberto I went also
in in a and Dakota in the United States
so I want to go in Egypt and then the
Egypt and Morocco and there was some
site that they were once upon a time it
was like like I'm talking about this
probably nobody cares but I I loved it
they were like tree giant apex predator
living in the same like a giant
crocodile circus ooh sushis car car and
auto doors and a Spinosaurus used to
live in the same area and wonder what
happened like three alpha freaking
predator living the same time and I
wonder if they interact with each other
and and it would it must have been a
crazy time and I have a friend and one
of his good friends has a ranch in
Montana and he found something on the
ranch and he called this paleontologist
and they went to his ranch and they shut
the place down like dude you got a t-rex
here really yeah they gave him over a
million dollars for it
yeah and they escalated this t-rex in
his ranch and apparently was a really
good specimen in Canada if you find
something it's part of it it belongs to
the government let's say let's say let's
say let's say you find a bone in your
backyard it doesn't belong to you can
you believe it yeah that sack man is
very bad that's when I was young Joe I
remember I used to live in countryside I
used to go and try to go to find bones
but I didn't know back then I was not
educated so I thought maybe I could find
diners I was spending hours and finding
trying to find dinosaurs every work I
took I thought it was a dinosaur used to
bring him back and my mom yeah it's a
dinosaur estate yeah right there because
it was kind of a triangular shape but
then I found out that all that place
where I come from it was all erosion so
there is nothing from Cretaceous or
Jurassic or Triassic back that it's all
like before that so it's all gone yeah
so just crazy man it's been a long time
I was in Montana once and there's this
area that used to be the Great Western
Inland Sea and this this area like the
ground is like this mucky ground
especially when it rains yeah it's
essentially silt like the bottom of a
lake you know that's because it was a it
was a like a sea in between England I
think cutting the amid the the cutting
the America in F yes yeah last year in
laramidia the to condemn continent yeah
you know all about that I know this man
I know as much as I'm MA with this Lily
almost yeah Wow like maybe not but I am
passionate with this man a long time
it's fascinating when you're walking
around this area in Montana it's called
the Missouri Breaks and because this
this ground it does feel like you know
if you've ever like seen a lake bed if
the water recedes got that silty sort of
weird mud this is all the whole ground
is like this yeah sticks to your boots
like it gets heavy and clumps on the
bottom of your boots like this muck
maybe man we don't know what the future
will look like man
sometime I'm thinking do I'm like you
know what people talk about the
environment and they say oh the
pollution will make we have hot hair and
Ice Age out there it's been going
forever so I'm thinking I'm like yeah
okay of course the pollution and the
human as an effect on the climate the
climate yeah but I wonder how much have
a how big we have an ethic some people
say is it's debatable is it is it that
big or is not that big some some sizes
yes it is bad some says yeah it's bad
boys we don't have that much of an
effect as you know we I don't know but I
would like to have a clearance or 2 2 to
4 days I think I think we have an effect
but I like I wonder how now we're going
in a hot air the glacier for our
mounting but the hot here will will will
go to a nice age you know that right
because of the current and everything so
I wonder out you know how much of an
effect and how long will it take you
know because we don't have any record
recent record of how long everything
takes we know a little bit but not that
much you know it's a fascinating subject
would be
are we gonna live through that time
probably not but I'm laying you know
what I mean it's like how long it will
take
I'm very interesting about that that's
why I love the this thing learning from
that past make you understand something
the present and in the future anyway I
think is really interesting ya know I'm
very fascinated by it are you still
interested in aliens yeah man this deal
so that's the thing when I first came on
your show yeah you cut me really off
guard because most most people that we
talk about aliens they they completely
think you're crazy or you disregard it
so you gotta talk about like you know
they most people that I attract with
their you know they so you feel like
ridicules
right then I and then after I found out
you you read a lot about that stuff like
the Sumerian texts the creation tablets
a conversation answer and I I do too I I
mean I don't know if there's like if
there is a you know like III think they
would be life-form I don't if it's
intelligence we don't have evidence for
it and I think or ego as human being
want us to believe that the alien came
and interact with us yeah that's our ego
but if they're that foreign advanced
from us and they come from a different
world
maybe they don't want to interact
because we have nothing to offer them
they're not gonna kidnap the farmer and
ask him what kind of suspension is
wearing you know what I mean like they
they think it you know what I mean it's
is but think about what you just said
about paleontology
I mean we're paying attention to stupid
[ __ ] lizards that lived sixty-five
million years ago it's true I mean don't
you think they would be curious this
weird monkey with nuclear weapons yeah
but we don't communicate with it we
don't think direct we observed there's
ways that it can learn from us without
communicate I don't know I mean it's I
think it's our ego that make us we want
to feel special we want to feel that
that like are we with different you know
like we were different beings then for
example a dog or yeah we can think
because we're smart but like I don't
know how it this has been giving a
giving to us like I don't know you know
like and you were talking about it like
when I was young I used to have
like you talked about the last time you
said oh you you were talking about like
the experience I said I remember that I
remembered but I can't recall it when I
was when I was young at I don't even
three my room I used to dry I used to
draw figure of monster I say my mom's is
the monster they come get me at night
that I was that's right that's what we
talked last time right but I was I was
very uncomfortable and I didn't want to
talk about it I was like man how the
hell he knows it you know everything man
this guy you knows everybody may
research that's so I I made I made the
drawing and then my mom even now today
today I wonder I want to see the drawing
you know like I and I and they I show
the drawing and I'm like and then I then
after I remember later I remember that I
remember but I couldn't remember you
know someone I mean I remembered that I
remember that something that happened
but now I can't remember what exactly
happen right could be a nightmare could
be another slip sleep paralysis or
process my my imagination I don't have
evidence you know what I mean that's
what we talked about it last time and
that's what that's what happened to me
and and and and I hope I hope it's not
me it's nightmare you know what I mean
but but the thing is
later on I saw some documentary on TV I
saw some people that the similar
experience as me
loss of memory and things like this when
they were young and they claimed they
they got a they got a head nose and
stuff then they they they go back and
time and they explained again and
abducted by an and then I start to
freaked out about it because I said them
is that what happened to me I know but
there was more a lot more logical
explanation you know what I mean
but that's why when he brought that back
I freaked out the hell you know was this
like how the hell you know is this I guy
I didn't want to talk about him at any
then it was also my agent was there hey
we need in ten minutes I mean I like I
didn't we were misinformed we didn't
know that podcast was like that long in
this house I all these thing in my head
I baby baby and I didn't know what to
make of it you know so that's that's
what it was yeah
it's entirely possible that we're
experiencing something when we're
dreaming that we're angry sleeping well
we're unconscious that maybe there's
dimensions that the consciousness
travels to that are non-physical that
like this this dimension what we're in
right now we can touch this table move
this microphone around these are
physical dimensions but it's entirely
possible that whatever your spirit is or
your consciousness or your your mind
when when when you're you're thinking of
your thoughts your soul that you say you
say you said you're a soul yeah whatever
that means you believe is this is a soul
you don't know what that means
okay okay it's a weird word right so
really it has religious connotations but
I agree but the idea of whatever your
essence is as a human being there's
something inside of all of us that makes
us conscious and aware and and there and
then that something is not there when
you're sleeping and so is it dormant is
it just recovering which is you know the
scientific version of it or is it
possible that while you're in this dream
state and your your body shuts off that
your mind and your consciousness travels
to a non-physical dimension that you can
only access through the chemicals that
are released in your brain which we know
produce psychedelic experiences so if
you took the chemicals that are released
during your brain or inside your brain
like dimethyltryptamine and there's all
sorts of different psychedelic chemicals
that are produced by the mind
if you take these outside of you know
the dream state if you take these drugs
you have these crazy fantastic
experiences and we know these are
produced by the brain that produce a
produce by the brain are produced by the
brain wasn't produced by the liver and
the lungs we believe they're produced by
your third eye which is your pineal
gland they've shown the Cottonwood
Research Foundation is thrown that this
this is done in rats that rats produce
dimethyltryptamine in their pineal gland
it doesn't necessarily mean that people
do but it's logical to imply that people
probably or conclude that people
probably do it as well so those those
chemicals that are producing these
psychedelic experiences are being
released by the brain
we don't know why and we don't know what
they're doing when you sleep
I gather guy Mathieu Walker yes it was
amazing when you sleep you're your
guardian your logic is not there that
part of your brain is gone yeah so we
could that's probably the most logical
experience but it's it's kind of a
freaking scary thought of thinking that
man is I it make you wonder sometim
sometime you at night that you're at
night alone in your thinking and I'm a
I'm a guy that think a lot you know I'm
thinking about all kind of scenario like
in a fight if I think about it also no
but in life I'm the same way
you're thinking what if this happened
for real or what if like man it's sick
scary we talk and it's it's it's a it is
nothing more scary in the world but what
is scarier is it scary to think that
when you die you're just gone and
nothing happens
or is it scary to think that your
consciousness leaves this physical
dimension and goes into what's
essentially a well of souls just a
dimension a non-physical dimension of
consciousness where all consciousness
interacts with each other and it's just
geometric patterns that don't have a
physical being attached to them it's
it's it's hard for me to believe the
consciousness is not Material material
because that's how you would say
sometimes people have they say always a
good person is a bad person I don't
believe there is good and bad person I
believe there is no people no baby born
good or bad I believe is your
environment and that makes that shape
you and it has a lot to do with it have
a lot to do so we say they the mind
let's say I'm a certain I'm a person I'm
a certain way you know me as a certain
way and it happened to me I know I have
a friend that happened to me was my best
friend and he's dead now unfortunately
he was a certain way but he got a car
accident
remember after his car accident he
changed man he was not the same guy he
become a little bit paranoid yet some
kind of dementia yeah so the person I
knew was kind of dead yeah but it was
physically the DNA everything was the
same but is this the person is different
right so when
you say the soul the mind it would be
really not material ik my materialistic
that would not have changed but his
personality was completely different is
he at the short temper
remember your girlfriend was extremely
jealousy he was starting to beat her and
stuff it was completely different
completely different person that you
knew before so if they say the mind your
brain your brain is materialism but your
mind is not so if you have if you big if
you have like if you have an accident
like my friend I maybe you have some
sort of dementia or something that's
mean if it's not materialism it would
not happen it's possible but it sorry
sorry to say any and you have the the
explanation that are like subjective and
objective if I pinch you you say I'm
hurt there is no objective way to for me
to to tell you that you really hurt
because even if I go away I open your
brain I can't see it no the only way I
know it's because of my experience but
it can't prove it right [ __ ] who
knows who knows it's also possible that
when you think of consciousness or the
soul or the what's going on in the mind
that is it's expressed through the body
and then what the body is damaged that
consciousness is damaged as well because
your consciousness is now being
expressed through a lack of certain
hormones your your your your mind itself
the very brain might be an antenna or
something that uses consciousness in
order to move through life but that
consciousness is independent from the
brain and that the brain being damaged
is just expressing consciousness in a
fucked-up way because you've got
dementia or Parkinson's or what other
neurological disorders that people have
but at the center of it it's still the
same thing it's one of things that
people say when they have so maybe let's
say you you die you finish the best out
of you will you mean will still exist
somewhere somewhere out of you but you
independent of the body this is just
theories ok ok but there's there people
that believe that consciousness is
non-local and that the body
actually it's just like an antenna for
your consciousness now if the body is
damaged if your hormonal balance is all
[ __ ] up your neurological system is
out of whack you like one of the things
that Muhammad Ali said when they were
talking to him about his Parkinson's is
that he's still in there he just can't
express himself because his body had
been damaged by so many fights and so
many hard sparring sessions and so many
blows to the head that he wasn't capable
of expressing himself but inside he was
still the same guy but he was trapped
his consciousness was trapped in a
broken body
I see it's like that like a prison like
like a that's like a locomotion yes yeah
and you know when you think about CTE
like a lot of these football players
like you know that Aaron Hernandez guy
that was a murderer yet he was a
football player and they examined his
brain after he was dead and like this is
a one of the worst cases of CTE we've
ever seen after he killed himself in
prison they examined him and the the
idea is that your consciousness is
supposed to be expressing itself through
a healthy brain right through healthy
hormones a healthy endocrine system a
healthy neurological system and that in
that way your your brain can your
consciousness can express itself and do
so without any physical hindrances then
there's also psychological what what is
LT I was yeah but what age are you away
I just started at the moment you start
breathing and living there's some sort
of change that occur in your mind so
sure what is the LT state that's 15 12
one years old and Annie right you one
years old you're not the same person at
15 and 15 you're not the same as 30 I
think 30 or not the same as 16 I think
they're not there's no independence I
think they're all connected and I think
that you know the the physical vitality
of the body is important the vitality of
the minds important but I think there's
probably something you know when the
first time I saw a real dead body like
up close was my grandfather my
grandfather died and you know went to
the funeral they had the open casket
it's very strange but one thing that I
realized when I was standing there I'm
like he's not even there
not here like he's not here it's this
body I mean this might have been where
my grandfather lived he might have lived
in this body yeah it's not here anymore
yeah it was a very strange feeling to me
because it was like internally I
realized something I I get the fact that
he's dead and he's not moving that this
is his body he's been embalmed and they
put makeup on you and all this weird
[ __ ] but it was also this feeling like
he's not there he's gone
yeah you know what is the body then is
the body of vehicle for whatever you are
yeah you say this maybe one day we'll
know maybe we won't
it's very it's really yeah it's one of
those it's a couple questions as
conceptual it's also you know people
have their ideological reasons for
believing one thing or another there's
people that are Annihilus to think you
know it's over when it's over and then
you go to black and that's it you're
done
end of story nothing happens when you're
dead well you don't know that because
you're we don't never die we can't we
can't no yeah it's it's a real it's a
real open-ended questions I'm on the
same page as you for this I I do not
know
you know I I a lot of idea has been
presented to me a lot of the idea I
rejected because it didn't make sense to
me logically like that scent
like all day do you believe in free will
right that's a good if my phone is there
and default there's a reason why it
falls the asymmetry of the phone make it
fall maybe I I bloom it is a reason I
won't say my phone only fell but if you
if you do something wrong for example
you kill someone you just not decided
like kill someone like there's a reason
why you do something and if you go back
the reason there's a reason of the
reason of the reason it's like it's like
a dumb you know yeah yeah sometime I'm
thinking I'm like man make me think like
I have no choice right
like how are you world champion you work
for us I ever had no choice well so I
have no no I don't deserve any props
because no choice right you are the
product of your life experience to me
that's what makes the most sense for me
yeah people think I'm crazy but I have
an argument with a lot sometime like a
lot of really just people they say oh
yeah but that but like I I that's why I
believe I believe sometime like it
doesn't mean I don't believe
even God or I don't it doesn't mean I'm
different like in my belief but I
believe I have no choice if I do
something I don't know choice but you do
have ethics and you do have morals and
you do make decisions so that's where it
gets slippery I don't think I made
decision
no and in the day it was a cause to that
decision there was a cause to everything
and by definition there is a cause there
is no free will
well it's a good argument I've heard it
I mean Sam Harris argued it to me the
best and made me really reconsider and
Robert Sapolsky who is a famous
scientist and and deals with a lot of
the functions of the human brain in
terms of like our motivations for things
he's his take was that in the future
that will be you know when we look back
today at like people that burn people
for witchcraft and stuff like that how
foolish they are yeah he thinks we will
have the same reaction to people judging
and punishing people based on their
behaviors I agree a hundred percent Wow
we'll just look go back in time in the
back in the I think it's an ancient
Greek mmm-hmm the man that will get
teaching knowledge to kids in exchange
of sexual favor there wasn't it you know
it happened yeah now we call that
pedophilia it's it's it's it's wrong
it's we we put the people in prison but
back in the day was normal you know what
I mean sometimes our conception of good
and bad or our choice you know I choose
like I don't I don't know many I don't
believe there is good and bad I don't
believe that choice I don't I have a
hard time to believe I choose something
well there's certainly things that you
think are more positive than negative
right like to my mind to people and
friendly to people's more positive than
being you know a murderer yeah that's
how you have a gun let's say you you
want to kill someone it's a charge can
you borrow me a gun please
as I oh yes I'm nice a nice gesture I I
will give you a gun but then you go kill
someone so is my gesture is nice or is
not nice
it good bad at all the event of all you
see Joe is all they been about you see
hands on why you giving the person a gun
right hey this guy raped a little kid
give me your gun
I'm gonna go kill them like oh yeah I'll
go do a good thing and I'll let you
borrow my guns and go kill this back
okay okay then my argument is okay you
want to go you said George give me your
gun I want to go kill this guy okay I go
give you the gun this guy is a dull
fiddler you go kill him it's a good
thing or bad thing to certain people
will be goods or certain people will be
bad it depend what's good bad yeah
decide it some time thinking like man
all this we who knows then you know we
freakin don't know man that's like the
interesting thing about life is that
there's a lot of things in life that are
messy there's not there's not a simple
answer
yeah yeah so we have choices it's like a
pool game yeah if mathematically I can
like I thought I'd talk with Ferriss and
Pharisees is very smart study fact the
philosophy yeah a great philosophy like
fighting you fight a guy you study ass
pattern you know like when you do this
you do that when you do this you do that
so if you do this you think you will do
that but maybe you won't because the
environment has changed since then but
you you know it's the same thing so if
you play pool if I can measure the the
the strength that I hit the ball
ricochet on certain ball if I can
measure everything precisely I will know
where all the balls are ending up on the
table you agree with that where I guess
if I know the all the data of the
universe and I boom and I can predict do
I agree with that
it would be the same thing with you if I
know you by heart I know your genetic
background know all the data of the
universe and it's impossible to know if
I would know I will know specifically
what would you do
exactly right now if I do that you will
know how you would exactly react or what
you're about to say to me yeah that's
impossible so that's why that's why I
don't believe in it that's why I believe
I don't believe in free will I believe
it's all it could be measurable we don't
it's impossible to measure right and
then when you see people that are doing
good things and achieving good things it
motivates you to do good things and
achieve thing and that also changes all
the people around you and makes them
move in a certain direction as well and
if you
look at certain cultures that are
extremely negative and crime-ridden and
[ __ ] up they produce extremely
negative crime-ridden [ __ ] up people
yeah it's like there's there's all this
going on there is it the fault of those
people and that's one of the things that
people really criticize and I think
rightly so about like hardcore
right-wing people that think everyone
should be responsible for their own
actions I don't care if you grow up at a
crime-ridden neighborhood you stop doing
crime and you be a good person and
that's not an easy task the brain has no
way to know if if an information is
relevant or not if you grew up in a
Democrat system with Democrat value
you'll be if you're smart you'll be a
smarter Democrat if you grew up in this
same but in a republicanism you'll be a
smarter Republican however maybe there
are things in your environment that will
make you switch you know today we don't
eat you dad you like [ __ ] I'm gonna
be a Democrat exactly we don't know but
your brain has no way so sometimes yeah
there's our on TV like evil genius
mm-hmm the guy ie outcomes is so smart
but is a is an evil like light as it
comes to to what we talk about it no
good bad there is no good bad there is
no that's one when I fight I fight the
guys like Nick Diaz or if and I swear
it's true let's say I Drive my car and I
see has a problem with this government I
will stop to help him yeah came on Dewey
was not nice already
whoever it is I will do it because for
me it's I don't think you know it's not
that I'm nicest the way I think you know
that's who you are
yeah they exactly I have no choice to be
like I am it is what it is you know I've
gotten better at that as I've gotten
older better at forgiving people and not
holding grudges and not being upset at
people and if I see someone that I had a
problem with in the past just give them
a hug you know no I don't care yeah I
think it's it's it's it's not healthy to
carry around grudges and you make you
feel good sometimes it feels real good
and it feels real bad to keep that hate
and anger inside of you it festers away
and you think of well if he says this
time I say that mm-hmm [ __ ] him and he
shouldn't have done this well I
shouldn't have done that but yeah but I
only did that because he did this and
you play you have these little stupid
arguments in your head instead of just
saying hi and just be
friendly or saying you're sorry or
saying hey man I don't have a problem
there's a guy that a few years ago I I
drove my car on on the street and my
Charlotte second in the evening I see a
tall guy coming at me and he asks for
you beg for money
put down my window this guy I swear it's
true story he's a guy that used to bully
me in school well I say I don't want to
say his name and I say hey wait a second
I parked my name I parked my car parked
the car go talk to him the hell you
doing here man's eye and and he thought
that would be angry because when he see
me he saw is wrecked like like now I'm
world champion you know like I can't
beat the beat him up you know back in
the day was like three years older than
me was bigger it was beating me up in
the bus this guy now he see me is I kind
of a scare I get out of my car you don't
know you don't know if he should run or
nuts I go to him I say so what you do
here man Zack is like you you say yeah I
know but things doesn't go well for me
you know I'm like that's all right say
like man you're a tall guy good-looking
like what you're doing here man's like I
give him what I have left on me you know
like I don't remember like I got 100
something I give him I said get out of
here man it's like you're full of
potential as I get out of here man like
when I was young and when I wanted to be
like you you're a tall guy man you you
you're good-looking it's like full of
potential so he sorry seconds I was like
no no problem and then he say thank you
George and you get out then I don't I
don't hear about him few few weeks few
months later I go to my paradise for
having dinner then my dad say you know
come to the house a few days ago this
guy I'm like yeah I met him say yeah he
said you met him in the street but now
he said he came to thank you
he came he wanted to talk to you by said
you don't live here and I didn't want to
give you a number he said he said look
he said George he talked to me and he
said something changed my life now I
have a job and I and I felt good I just
want to say thank you to him and it
feels so good
now you just went when I met him and I
didn't get angry at him like you know
because it's it was
there we did very bad stuff to me when I
was young but when I see him it made me
feel good can ever relief now yeah and
this guy when I was young was beating me
up in the bus all the time it was
ridiculous ridiculous me I'd like adidas
pants that you can tie it like this it
was like take enough so I was like an
underwear and find everybody in front
the girl he was bidding me up all the
time and he was stronger than me was
like three four years older than me and
he was tall and strong guy is a key
player back in the day and yeah I
couldn't beat him even with martial
right he was always stronger than me he
hurt me a lot like back in the day him
so my dad one time I was got beat up in
the bus so I told him because I came
back with a black eye one time in my
life I told my dad what happened I never
said anything but I saw my dad I say
he's a guy in a bus he beat me up he
said I tell him the name of the guy so
my dad what he did he found out were I'm
from countryside so everybody knows who
everybody lives he goes to the house you
know I can't ever talk to the daddy say
listen stop can you tell your son to
stop hitting my son in the bus because
he need to be focused on the school and
that dad when my dad came back he said I
want to talk to his dad he's gonna stop
so he said it is that it was like
drinking and stuff and it was beating
the [ __ ] out of his son so the way this
guy learned to communicate to his dad
was beating up he was drunk and beating
him up that's the way he committee was
community communicating with me it was
beating me up because he learned that
the same way from his dad to communicate
so I was just happened to be at the
right right the wrong time at the right
time in his life at the perfect you know
I was the guy that was getting beat so
he's a good and bad he was not a bad
person to my version of life from my
perspective he was a terrible person
like that he was terrible I wanted to
kill him yet like many my and my school
time miserable man I was Amelie ated all
the time I was getting beat up a lad I
was very proud person so I used to to go
fight him all the time
because I was proud and I won't point I
thought him so many times that this guy
is complaining and saying I stop
buttering him because that was what's
never going to giving up even though I
was beating getting beat up all the time
but to my eye oh my he was a bad person
but true his eyes it was a different
story and to his father was a different
story today everybody it was a different
story
yeah just to say that when I met him
that way we talked about it feels so
good
just to meet him in the street and make
kind of a peace and give him money like
yeah you beat me up you didn't but you
know what even though you did that I
give you the money and I make me feel
like I'm kind of a revenge better than a
revenge you make me feel like yeah man
you see without me you wouldn't have
nothing maybe to sleep or eat tonight so
I give it to you I still give it to you
if you do that to me that make me feel
much better than if I would like read
them up yeah and don't you think that
maybe that guy in him doing that to you
was one of the reasons why you became a
champion because you you got in the
martial arts very heavily because of
being yeah the guy was beating up and
school maybe it was maybe it was not the
only guy that was beating me up all his
friend but he was kind of the the guy
that was all the girl liked and he was
like the taller stronger guy so he was
kind of the Alpha guy at the time maybe
it was an influence I don't believe only
one thing influenced me but it's many
things many cars that make that happen
but maybe it's one of the cars yes yeah
that's crazy I could be wrong I could be
right but that's what that's my
philosophy in life that's how I think so
everybody says Oh George your true
martial artist you're a good guy as I
thank you right I don't have the time to
explain to them everything I just told
you right but that's how I think in my
when they say you're a good guy of Zion
thank you I'm not [ __ ] good guy Evan
and me and myself I am dying but it make
me happy when people say that you are
good guy you try to be a good I try to
be a man you are
yeah trying to be who you are I try to
try to be good model good role model I
think is important for me to my value
that had been raised and yeah
but doesn't mean like I don't like other
guys I like the guys and I like the most
to watch their fight they're not the
good guy yeah my favorite fighters to
watch are not the good guys
Chael Sonnen i like to watch him the
Nick Diaz I like to watch Nick Diaz
I like Conor McGregor when he fights I
like him yeah the good guys are boring
them they're boring guys they make me
fall asleep
I like the drama I like even though I
don't act like it I like it we will be
like it I know it's completely
contradictory I like I love the seat or
T's back in the D was my favorite man
store at ease men he was amazing
came with his flag like bad bad guy man
I love them
Star Wars I love the Sith Lord much
they're much more charismatic than the
the Jedi are you kidding me Jedi Karate
Kid the new the new karate kid I watched
the first episode of moping Danielsson
get beat up all the time you know Johnny
Lawrence I hope you smash his head you
didn't do it so you know what I mean I
think that makes me a bad person
no it's nice I like you know it's
different that way that's how you see
things you know right when you see a
lion chasing the gazelle do you root for
the gazelle
I hope the lion catches the gazelle yes
exactly exactly yeah is that good or bad
like these people and don't eat meat
it's not natural
right like what is natural what is not
natural man it's an interesting
conversation you talk about this it
people think odd saint-pierre is just so
you just get hit in the head too many
times but it's just my English is good I
can communicate it to true it with you
like like it's easier I feel more
comfortable yeah and and it is what it
is but I thats why i like it because
you're a person too
I'm kind of a big fan of you too and I
know you I didn't know that in the
beginning when I first to know you but I
now I know that that you get interested
in the same thing that I am interested
and what I like about you too is you
don't give a damn you do whatever you
have no bus you do whatever you want
whenever you want with who you want I
mean I respect that it's kind of a code
you have your own code that you do and I
respect that
I like human being like this I like too
to be with human being like this guys I
have no code animal like this I don't
know me my circle of friends short you
know I have a few Gaia lichens that I
keep the the I'm diplomatic with a lot
of people but I'm not friend with a lot
of people yeah Maddie because I have to
be for that for my work for my business
for the person I am and I don't like
confrontations I'm diplomatic but
there's I mean I like everybody you know
well I think your relationships that you
have with people the exchanges you have
with people it's very important to keep
only positive influential strong people
around you because you learn and you
grow from those people and they give you
fuel when you're around people who are
inspirational or doing interesting
things who live their life by a code who
are ambitious who succeed who try hard
difficult things those are the people
that inspire and give you energy and I
feel better around them I feel like I
get energy from them versus people that
are always making excuses and people
that are always falling short people
that fail all the time and people that
complain all the time those people the
opposite and those people they take away
from you and you're around them you just
like oh I just gotta get away from this
guy however it doesn't mean that the
good people that you have in your life
will always be the good people for
different situations right example
before fights my families I stayed the
hell away from them
I'm explain to you why it's my family
they care about me I remember before
fights before I used to go eat at my my
parent with my parent my family used to
be like the last dinner day they'll say
they eat their soup they look at me
are you okay you feel good you're not
sick and before a fight I need to feel
like I'm going to war with my soldier I
need to feel that what I'm doing its
normal events though is not yeah so when
I hang out with with my family they have
a normal life so what I do they see me
like an outcast I collect man these guys
it's completely insane is about to go
fight in a cage you can die oh my god
and I feel that because I love me so my
family before the fight stay away from
them I stay away from a lot of the
people that I love
my circle of friends I love like family
and I bring back closer to people like
like Ferris Joan the fighters guys even
guys that are maybe not as much as my
friend a like son send them in town yes
so it make me feel normal it make me
feel strong because we're going to war
when you're going to war you don't bring
a yeah wife your kid your your family
and you bring the people that you go in
war with you know what I mean it's very
important for me so it's it's it's
depending what's going on I believe us
good and bad people you know it's not
always good now it's bad depending the
context you know ya know that makes a
lot of sense yeah especially then being
nervous about your fight like nerve that
that energy is contagious Pro I'm
already nervous like like it is I don't
want to be more nervous and I hate I
hate like I hate fighting people's I
know you I don't I really do and and I
know you maybe a lot people don't
believe me but I'm gonna extra explain
the best I can
in every in every jobs there is no
perfect job do you agree that there is
there is no perfect job that you like
every everything about it it's
impossible
my job as a professional athlete and
mixed martial art on 365 days I fight
normally when I was very excited to
fight twice a year approximately not
more than that I never wanted to more
than that because I wanted to stretch
especially when you want to stretch when
your champion because it's better for
advertising the the also for longevity
and everything so more time more money
more business and everything and
longevity so about two twice a year in
charge of sixty-five days there's two
days that I hate the most is the day
that I'm fighting it's freakin
unbearable the feeling of uncertainty
that if you don't know if you're gonna
be milli ated you're gonna be the victor
we're gonna be the loser
it's I care so much about it that is
freaking unbearable as much as I try to
dismiss it
it's unbearable however I like the fact
that I'm a free man I'm my own boss I do
whatever that whatever I have I have
access to certain things like VIP stuff
that most people don't and my quality of
life the money I didn't have it before
now I do I love my job
I have very happy about my job but there
is thing about my job that I hate the
most is fighting I freaking hate I love
the study of fighting I love the science
of it how I'm the tactical the physical
I love to Train I love to walk in a room
I'm strong I know if something happened
I'm the man even though it's an illusion
because with a bullet and nobody is
faster than this but I like that
lifestyle I do for the lifestyle for
what it is I don't do it for the fight I
freaking hate to fight I had this talk
with Rory MacDonald on one point never
say why you like fight it
oh I guess I like to fight so you like
to fight it's like [ __ ] no I and
everybody in the room turn around they
look at me like I'm crazy all right you
guys are all crazy
I'd like to find an occasion for million
of people may be getting Milly ated
knocked out or died are you crazy I
don't like to fight are you nuts
I like to win when you win you're it's
the feeling is unbelievable it's so good
that it's worth this yeah but I hate it
man do you hate the day of the fight up
until the fight but once the fight
starts how do you feel once it starts
nananana and when it started it's gone
all this and all the anticipation scum I
like I hate the day to build up that day
and the closer I get to the day I start
I love it but I start to hate it more so
I can build a hate that build up like a
ball of hate and by that time that is
time to freaking walk out there's like
that many second that it's time to walk
out and I birth what son used to be that
guy used to kick out the door sorry are
you ready now he's not there anymore
unfortunately
like birdies so I just it's like a
bubble that buildup in my stomach that
hate hate hate and I freakin a time even
in the locker room before the fight and
I [ __ ] ate it my last fight I crazy I
saw my friend a man got knocked out and
I'm going to dinner everybody's like
that people like this and I see where
something as wrong as it was wrong as I
they told themselves before I get in the
room don't tell them that that a man
lost don't tell him is gonna affect him
so I get in the room and my friend Eddie
who wasn't there one day when they
tailed each other first thing you said
to me is like in the road I am endless
and I owe you said okay physically is
that yeah it's okay and everybody's like
holy [ __ ]
so em and last I remember Jody Phyllis
Mickey got lost so I go in Myra in my
locker room I see one guy with the ice
bag the other guy is all [ __ ] up like
this and I'm like man all my locker room
loose man
holy [ __ ] I freaking hate this job man
then I'm thinking is like everybody
tried to take like oh it's gonna be good
it's one of my agents like don't worry
it's gonna be fine as I as I it's okay
man don't talk to me like this I choose
be here I'm a warrior and so go go sit
now it's gonna be fine like I want to be
a warrior yeah oh it's gonna be fine
don't worry and they go now you know
they go like this yeah use that first
time they go like this guy they grab me
like the whole region's got to be funny
look each other like I'm feeling like
I'm going to a like a semi like a
cemetery like someone just died so I'm
in the locker room everybody freaking
knows I'm like damn
then I'm like shake it up I go in the
bathroom by myself I go I go look at
myself in the mirror and that's why I do
before the fight I used james-lange
theory
James Naja's is a they say that the
spirit can dictate your mind you say you
you thirsty your mind tells I'm thirsty
you grab the water and your spirit can
take
state your mind but your mind can
dictate your spirit so I go in the
bathroom
close the door people think I go to
bathroom to piss or whatever but I don't
close the door and I say I said now I
see a lot of negative [ __ ] I go I go in
from the mirror I say to myself say I
say try to convince myself like a kid
you know like I'm the greatest I'm the
stronger son and I think I think of it
looking at me and I'm this I'm beautiful
I'm strong and this and then I'm faster
I'm stronger I'm gonna win as like this
young guy they lose but I'm gonna show
them what the way to do it you know
maybe they they fell but I won't I'm
gonna show everybody how it should be
done so I come back in that gym with the
with the glory to show them that I
achieve it and that's how it should be
done if they're gonna follow me man so I
try to boost myself open the door go go
back I still hate my job but I am a
different person than when I got in the
door so I play with mind games like this
with myself all the time stuff that I
had that that tried to change your
attitude and it's very important for a
fighter because the confidence is a key
for a fighter some guy they do stuff
very basic and a fight but they do it
when they do it they do it so good and
they believe in it they notice it tight
and you have no room for is it a shenana
fight you go 100% and when you go 100%
with confidence that's when the magic
can happen you know what I mean if you
have the skills but you don't have the
confidence isn't it John says that you
have the skills and you have no
confidence it's like having money and
you don't spend it that's what John De
Niro told me but if you have the
confidence without the skills it's not
good - it's like a dream that cannot be
achieved you don't have the anyway
together but if you have both that's
when the magic can happen I remember
when John Johnny says that to me all the
time so you have this skill and you have
the confidence and confidence is not a
choice is is a confidence that is not a
state of mind is a choice man you can
build it in your head when something bad
happen you build it and work try to work
on your person to build it this is
something you can work on yourself you
know and that's why I've been doing yeah
it's like all these other things you're
saying it's there's
there's no one answer to how all this is
done all those pieces have to come
together all those pieces have to be
together
in order for you to be able to just go
out there and do it but I love the fact
that you say that you don't like it I
freaking hate it I hate it probably even
in the locker room when I got there what
I've got there that night and like every
other night that I'm finding asked by my
agent has given for us I always tell my
look at him is like so what the hell I'm
doing here what stupid and they we
always laugh at it because now it's
become at the point that I know I know
it because I I with experience you do
you become more courageous you become
you say do you lose the fear you know
lose the free never lose affair you
learn how to deal with it you accept it
before I didn't I did not accepted my
earlier fight like might use my first
time I found my use I man I was fighting
this monument this oh my god is like I
didn't sleep for that week man I came
like a freakin zombie I was like oh my
god I came even in the staredown I could
even look at him I look up like this
it's like I couldn't imagine myself I
knew I was going to lose the confidence
was not there I have that skill is not
the confidence so it's very important
the confidence you know is for a fighter
confidence it's very important that's
why you have guys in the gym that are
very good in the gym they get into a
fight they shitty fighter their King in
the gym they're gonna fight all that
stuff crush them you have guys they're
normal in the gym I've seen guys in UFC
they fight in UFC Dave freakin padded I
can't say for the respect but I spar
with them and they suck when they fight
they do stuff that it's amazing I'm like
an even know it that wasn't his
repertoire of technique that he just did
I can't Academy or a thong I'm like man
it's amazing I'd even knew he knew that
right because of a confidence man and
when you have both the skill and the
confidence like you see like John Jones
man is Magic Man you go there spinning
freaking elbows and some like you don't
easytek egos man yeah yeah Rodriguez is
amazing
and stuff like that it is just beautiful
to watch you know and I really like that
the new generation and it scary as hell
oh my god what which fight excites you
more Connor or khabib those are the two
fights if I was gonna make a fight for
you right right now right now it's like
that the big five the thing is with
cabby be calling me out physically now
is it's not good time for me I need to
weigh a little bit however I feel the
155 division now is Connor is the
champion is Ferguson I think Ferguson is
out and and there's other guys too but
there's the two guy corner and cab like
cabbie now I think is that champion but
you need to fight maybe the corner or
are to be like real champion I real is
the real chair I don't like to say they
real not champion what's and my opinion
on the belt is really different than
most people think I don't think even
think it should be about you know I
think you should be fight you know buddy
but it is what it is and I agree with
you on it make fun fight there's no belt
like I said you cannot be the strongest
man in the world it's an illusion right
the belt it claim elevate someone like
you think is that God is a strongest lay
men in there now is not what's a good
marketing to that that eighth ranked guy
I can beat you but maybe cannot beat the
seven other in front of you yeah or they
said you know what I mean there's six
other so I don't know how it could be
done I know it's bad to criticize a
system if you don't suggest any
alternative I know it's better what I do
but it's well the problem is influx
anyway right because Tony was the
interim champion and he didn't do
anything to lose it all he did is fall
down while doing press obligations tears
me apart and then you have Connor who
just didn't defend it and then they
stripped him and so you're gonna give it
to khabib but he's fighting a like
Quinta who ordinarily wouldn't be
fighting for the title so why is why is
he have the potential to fight for the
title it doesn't make any sense they had
to do it for this event because they had
this big event in Brooklyn and they had
to have a champion so they decided to
sell they're gonna do it but you got to
be careful when you make decisions like
that yeah because you in
people's eyes in the eyes of the purists
UD legitimise they lose value yes I
agree 100% he lose value to is
especially like what I did make lose
value to fight and Rick's left-side
Bisping left they freaking hate my guts
that's why I don't think so though
because I think it makes me it's not
good for the brand is not good and I
know it's not good I'm not stupid I
realize it but I had no choice man I go
back there and not in condition you know
whatever happened I think it was not my
name Robbie Lawler won the title and
then Robbie Lawler lost the title the
tyron woodley nobody doesn't think the
tyron woodley is the legitimate champion
because you retired no I mean it's it's
it's a clear path it makes sense then
understand the same thing like I said
it's not WWE man I have to do what is
the best for me and I don't regret my
decision it is I regret that I've stayed
too long I should have retired maybe
take my first stop after Diaz
because Diaz was the fight a big fight
and what you know what I mean it was
like the main guy you know to fight then
after Russian but it there's always a
guy Joe that's a thing
there's always another freakin guy
that's the way this sport you know we
always believe that after that wall it
would be no wall but now man is always
another another another another in and I
realize that it's and every fight are
more expected than other and our bigger
and another and it is what it is man is
what it is it's a hard very hard life
mentally like depend on your wire
psychologically for me it was a lot to
take one thing it's a lot reason for me
I have a theory about that one of the
reasons why it's a lot to take because
you're smart I think smart people they
they entertain all the possibilities
they think about all the possibilities
they're aware of all the variables and
I'm a thinker I think Alice yes analyze
I think a lot I mean it's good because
it's prepared you very well and it's
made you this incredible martial artist
but it's also creates a lot of anxiety
because you're aware of all the
possibilities where as a person who
doesn't think that much just I'm just
gonna go in there [ __ ] people up like
that person might have an easier path to
fight but they might also have a shorter
limited potential absolutely because
they're not aware of all the
possibilities and they're not aware of
all their flaws and
not aware of other strengths and
weaknesses they just know what they've
done that's worked and they just keep
doing that and instead of developing
this incredibly well-rounded game they
have a very very limited game but that
limited game works on some people I
agree it's it's it's this part that the
sport in general it's kind it's kind of
not fair when you look at it likely look
like Demetrius Johnson's probably right
now the best ever the best ever yeah I
agree like man when I talk about
confidence and skills man what is the
better guide in this what better guide
and this Dominick Cruz freaking amazing
man TJ Dillashaw that's one fight look I
don't watch every fight again
I don't watch every fight because I'm
not a fan of every fighter but if
there's a fight that I will pay my own
ticket to sit in front and fly myself is
Dominick Demetrius Johnson against TJ
Dillashaw absolutely a man has to be
done it has to be done I don't there is
always things and factor that we don't
know why it doesn't happen maybe we
don't know everything unfortunately and
yeah like like back in the day me and
understand silver it's a lot after why
it didn't happen is there stuff that
people don't know that led back in the
day I thought and then I wanted to take
care and then happen but there's this
fight man is just crazy man sometime is
sudden the sport light like you have
fight like Mayweather Mayweather
Pacquiao and it did not happen it sucked
but it is what it is you know I think
that Demetrius wants TJ Dillashaw to
fight once at 125 pounds show that he
can make the weight especially when he's
dealing with this incredibly long win
streak he's defended his title more than
any other champion ever so he doesn't
want someone to come along and break his
win streak that doesn't even make every
way they did this as a I have thought
about this because I've been in a
similar situation yeah this is a way to
take care of this with the lawyers you
brighten the contract that if you don't
make weight is no fight and the purse
you make the guy
you a purse not that you see Dillashaw
will take the man's give the purse you
know what I mean yeah no I do but no
need to be game enough to do it it's a
freakin risk yeah yeah but I think
Demetrius is worried that the UFC will
pressure him into fighting TJ even if TJ
doesn't make the way so we have TJ made
sure for sure it will make him look bad
in terms of with the fan base and his
brand I agree however he can make it
through the lawyer to the if it's that
much weight difference there is no fight
right you know there's always fights man
Joe there's something I've learned fight
can be negotiate the way you want I can
negotiate a fight like depending the the
laws okay I want you to wear pink
speedos when I fight you it's under
contract you have to wear a spring
speedo I want you to wear this or any
like a fifth-round or if it's everything
could be done if it's written and and
and by the law agreed
yeah it could be worked out I don't
think - my husband will be like this
guys let's do it man let's go
well I think right now the rematch is
set for Cody gar Brandt vs. TJ Dillashaw
and Mighty Mouse just went through
shoulder surgery yeah so he's
rehabilitating his shoulder that's gonna
take quite a while and that there's the
minute the minute crews doing the mix
man it's amazing yeah he's amazing I
like to watch him a lot yeah there's a
lot of talent there's a lot of talent
right now the smaller guy are so much
better than the bigger guy
like I'm telling you the truth like like
if I would have the same size as this
guy a minute I don't want to fight this
guy man I would beat the [ __ ] out of me
like now man they don't have gravity
[ __ ] with them I agree they know that
the gravity they not have that size but
they're so good my is so good to watch
them yeah I'm learning I'm learning a
lot I watch a lot more of these guys and
then in terms of for learning yeah men
how beautiful was that armbar that
Demetrius Johnson is it [ __ ] many
slammed well I slam to the armbar in the
air and he said now I practice at the
moment ready
you learned I learned from these guy man
I learned from a lot of these guys yeah
did you switch man every time he's
changing Dominick Cruz man is footwork
man it's very trained with Duane Ludwig
long time ago yes I
Sparra we train when I was in Denver
helping Nathan Marquardt for a fight I
spire
man it was crazy spar with Dwayne Nate
shank a twin - oh my god shank yeah that
was that smart but I did yeah
[ __ ] that yeah that wasn't that smart
that was back in the day maybe I should
have been smarter by and this is because
your head thanks God I didn't get hurt
but oh my god it was yeah I'm up I
remember in a training EEE he wasn't
grounded pounder with another guy that
is like a light everybody knock him out
yeah he's a big monster but that was
stupid on my part when I when you're
young you do stupid [ __ ] I should not
have done it yeah [ __ ] that huh what did
he way back then he weighs a mere or him
I just say car whinnies might be like
270 yeah he's a big guy [ __ ] huge I
know it that was stupid but I did it and
then you know you move man you got a
[ __ ] move yeah man hit ya hit and run
man run don't try to stand in the pocket
with this guy and if you go for it take
that you go in and out and then quick
man holy [ __ ] yeah your timing has to be
perfect yeah [ __ ] that the only one
round yeah one round yeah yeah we went
with everybody you know there's this
thing like I when we train with other
guys especially I went with I train with
everybody I train with John Jones I try
which part with everybody with it's it's
good experience there you know and
there's guys that that's par like it's
their life depend on it like it's a real
fight there's other guys of course
depending if you get ready for a fight
or not and and if you you know depending
the situation but there is when it's
just aspiring for sparring that you're
not in training camp or whatever you
spar but there's still guys that I see
younger guy they they they know they
lose a lot of their their years of
fighting in the gym because they fight
in the gym and it's not good for your
brain man yeah hole you should I never
be a big been a big fan of this ya know
I feel like even now in my last sparring
guys they come hard and you but I have
to go hard because otherwise I gotta
hurt me but that's not because of me
that's because my frickin trailer is
telling them
you gotta put in my way we're gonna
praise it you know what I mean so why
does frost do that he's cupping
completely crazy for ass man is insane I
love him to death but man he's
completely insane he's my son sighs my
spy may I call him pay me John I'll you
know John I call him the Emperor yeah
John is our that we all have nicknamed a
tough guy John is another one like when
I'm in training camp and he put me with
Gordon Ryan Gary tore the one after Jake
she like a go go go go with them and I
get smashing I get out like a pretzel is
[Laughter]
[Applause]
good for my confidence sometimes it is
sometimes [ __ ] man I start to eat I have
a hard life it's a darkness inside
John's brain yeah man and it's hard hard
man I made it I made a lot of good
change man I'll ask for preparation like
you know I used to Train like an on the
ground I fight win fight around a
five-minute you're never gonna spend
five minute on the ground when you train
for an MMA fight so I did treatment
around with one minute break it makes
you an starting form scrambling position
like for example head head and arm
control then go right or mount position
go we didn't start like shaking and then
because you lose time while you're
making to start from position control at
a let go so it makes you more active in
when you fight make you more
opportunistic and now I teach at Tristar
12 arrests like I do it because I love
it at 12 FS and that's why I teach the
people no no more five minute round when
you train for an MMA fight true minute
round three minute round and
trimerization you will never spend the
entire five minute round and the minute
that you got to spend on the ground you
have to be very economic and very
important is when you see something boom
that's what I guess I would be spring I
see the neck boom
you know I let him stand up do the leg
drag or up block right away yeah I
probably would not have react the same
way a few years ago would would be more
taking a position and unsafe kind of
mentality you know what I mean we need
to learn to choke
yeah it was this way but I practiced it
a lot because I
learn the pattern of Bisping that when
you do this you like to do this so I
predict we've we've we've worked on it
you know like when I mean like it stuff
that we were II wasn't in my like I said
like my my autopilot already in my hard
disk so it's just reaction you're not
have time to think which before when you
don't train like this you train in five
minute it's slower price so you're
thinking more Jitsu is more it's not
much of a dynamic it's more easier
matrix port sometime you didn't I make
but is more so metric and position so
you don't want to be like this for him
and you want to be like bang bang bang
bang fast and you know what I mean make
your make you more you know what I mean
more efficient what kind of training
you're doing now I mean you're going to
train with Freddie Roach now yeah how
much time are you spending training I
train normally twice a day every day
still yeah I don't train hard every day
twice a day
some days I do once a day I try to train
at least four days a week that are twice
a day and maybe two days that are once a
day depending what I do for example only
gonna train once a day two days with
Freddie tomorrow ever I do it this new
thing now it's that really changed my
life to it I trained in a pool and all
that weight you know the Weig no man I
don't and I don't believe I still don't
believe in conditioning it's a
conditioning I don't I don't believe I
believe it's an illusion everybody has a
sufficiency so I want to get tired more
than the others because more efficient
because everybody at their certain level
is in shape you know but but I trained
in the pool I I do for example I have
resistance stuff equipment and I trained
in the pool so it's like my weight
training I do in a pool Wow for example
you do flies we have protagonist
antagonist muscle that works all the
time and it's like the wing flies but
instead of a yeah protagonist and
antagonist you do a fly and the pool in
the same time push pool and you're doing
it with rubber bands like we know it's a
resistance wingman no no II resistance
equipment is like a [ __ ] I wish I would
know your cable no sonic cable is like a
resistant it's like a handle
it's a new thing the Russian developed
this like in the eighties long time ago
we just start to learn now about it and
the Russian were way more advanced than
us and in its AG Gavin McMillan that
made me discover this form of training
when I rehab my ACL so he he hates to a
training he said hey wait trainee they
load up your joint it damaged your joint
you know and depending how you do it but
when you go evie damage your joint is
true that's why I look young and I feel
better at 37 now if it wouldn't wouldn't
be for this my my ulcer I feel better
now at 37 that I fell at 25 mark my word
is true the only difference is let's I
go out like my birthday was May 19 last
Saturday I got completely wasted drunk
it take me more days to recuperate
because I'm 37 and when I was 25 but
strength wise like I feel just more
powerful better yeah man we there's hope
for for the older man there's hope that
we can last better we can have a better
living it's kind of crazy that you don't
believe in strength the condition I
don't think that is the thing that
everybody does today
nobody is involved with strength and
conditioning because sometimes they mix
up their performance and strength
conditioning because of the steroid
believe a lot of people they say oh my
nutrition is because this is this or my
new training make me be stronger look
I'm a better fighter and ammon's maybe
it's because you taking something you
know what I mean yeah I believe it like
in in UFC let's say it I spoke with some
pro boxer okay for example like this
yeah yeah this one an example here so
you've got yeah well yeah but they
create a resistance on the way up you
see so it's I would say so it doesn't
load up my joint and you just explode it
yeah this is like pistol squat but a
there's like a hundreds like exercise
like this like a sound to it maybe not
hundred but there's so many yeah man
there's study you can do with your every
part of your body you can do an exercise
the Russians got it too yes and and also
the NFL football player a lot trained
with that because an increase your your
power it works so that thing that you
know that is the stability but if you
want to increase your power it
for increasing the power for muscle the
fiber of the muscle you know what I mean
you know it won't make you a better
fighter but it will longevity-wise keep
your your car your your your car vehicle
your vehicle else here that's why I do
string conditioning I don't do for
making me a better fighter I do it
because I want to look good I want to be
muscular I want to I want to be balanced
I want to be have a longer long
longevity it's not gonna make me hit
harder or stronger hell no Freddie Roach
might help me hit stronger for example
you know I mean John danara will make me
be more creative have better on bars and
Ferris will make me you know what I mean
like better fighter and in terms of
giving me knowledge and different things
that's what I believe could be wrong
from like like I know we think different
ways in that regard we argue before
about this but that's why the name
open-minded I'm gonna a lot of times I'm
arguing I'm just playing the devil's
advocate I don't think there's any one
way to do these things like example III
I spar for example or your jujitsu guy
make an experimentation go wrestle with
a real wrestler like a high-level
wrestler pure wrestler wrestle Wynnum
you're gonna get much die you're gonna
get tired much quicker than him for sure
how it's not because he's got a better
cardio than you you know or maybe is
like I did depending but then after that
go on the ground sit down and shake his
in and start rolling on the ground I
guarantee is gonna get more tired than
you because if you never done jujitsu
he's gonna spend a lot more energy ski
you're gonna be much more efficient than
him even though maybe as a better cardio
ninh than you if you take a vo2 max test
maybe he's gonna score better however
you more efficient it's all about
efficiency yeah they try to sell you the
product they try to sell you the program
that's all freakin at for tight vert
izing our life is made of advertising
that's why I was angry and I like we
talked about intermittent fasting like
there's no pills for this there is
nobody that makes money
that's why nobody talks about it but
it's so efficient the oldest remedy in
the world you know what I mean in three
days you can rebuild your your immune
system
and your gut all of it in three days are
fascinating you do it take an email a
assault with the water you go train it's
perfect you go in Auto fashi faces the
best you know I am but nobody talks
about the same thing and cards you and
all that they have to commercialise
always the money is it's all about
selling you the thing right our life
it's all about branding
everywhere we go with freaking
commercial we were surround by
commercial if you want it's under
something we don't even realize it
because it's so present in our life so
it's it's a second make me a better
fighter I do it because I felt good
could develop my muscle and it's good
for me to be you know to have muscle for
for my brand for for me for advertising
for even for myself feel good you know
what I mean feel solid you know I get it
yeah that's a real truth it's not gonna
make me hit you think this gonna make me
have a better hook now man it's it's it
doesn't transom like that right timing
precision forms you know everything it's
not if Joe Louis had the smallest arm I
think it one of the smallest army hit
like crazy I mean when you look at his
build it wasn't like a Mike Tyson my
friend had done it Stephenson like I
mean he's Billy's an adult he's an
athlete but man I sparred with him many
time and he hit like a [ __ ] truck he
sprayed the heaviest hitter ever seen in
my life you know what I mean yeah and
it's not like he's strong is that lyric
but there's guy that more more snook
look stronger than him or a bodybuilder
yeah because that's because of his form
the way transfer his weight is is vector
of force everything is technique is
timing is precision everything is
perfectly your own structure - usually
power your freaking bad kick man
like this something is not because you
were there and I said the per the human
being that I've hit that had produced
the highest amount of force that I have
a witness in my life is human with
you're free and I'm not saying that is
the truth I never seen a human being
physically capable of hitting something
with that much force than you is a
perfect example of what of what
argue it's not because you're stronger
yeah you're strong guy you're a good
athletic guy but you know like you
you're older you're older than me you
know like you like you know what I mean
like why because it's your form the
technique the vector of force your
technique everything is all freakin
perfect timing that's why it's when you
turn and you make that spin right I
don't care who you are if you Francis
and gun do you hit that [ __ ] on their
face you gonna be dead you know that not
that but you gotta be knocked out man no
this is crazy
you know what I mean when you did that
it was a completely insane you know yeah
that's that one Keith I'm still working
on it by the way but I I can't do like
you do with my knee coming out I feel
like when I do inspiring the guys they
they see it and they they so I have to
keep my my knee tuck yeah I think you're
just thinking that maybe it's because
the karate I learned in a different way
so my brain is wired so much in a
certain way the the problem with karate
is that lower knee then knee down by the
the other knee versus up by the hip when
you bring it up by the hip there's
there's much more leverage it's
tremendous amount of force and the
alignment of your lower leg the
supporting leg and the kicking leg is
better to generate force whereas the
kicking leg is almost independent of the
lower leg if you're going up because
they're not moving in the same direction
one leg is going up the other leg is
going forward so it's like it's all
goofy up when you turn the hip is up
this is pushing and this is going
forward it's just so however the power
comes you come from Taekwondo yeah is
all the Olympic athlete like champion
they don't do it like that yeah no no
exactly that you do it in a different
ways right but man I never seen anybody
hit as hard like I don't care if it's
upon check I never see a strike a strike
a blow from a human being that hard man
I remember that that bag when you were
working in it was a freaking hole almost
in the bag it was like a curves in the
bag like with your your footprint in it
I'm like it's completely insane man it's
a lot of power
I was with Eddie Brava where that every
we're freaking out then you
going back and forth at I like you yeah
well you know we work together because
of Danaher yeah cuz john came up to me
and just asking me because i was a
commentator yeah he said I need someone
to help George with the fundamentals of
a spinning back kick he needs like like
a technique refresher do you know
anybody and I said this is gonna sound
crazy
I just gotta listen to me but I have a
really good spinning back-kick so that's
how that's how you put it out smarted he
put it to me asking no no II knew he
said no you know that he told me he's
gonna ask you he's gonna ask if you
could work with me that's funny because
he said it's me no no no I knew somebody
no but you want to put it this way this
Johnnie's smart guy Johnny's very smart
guy at you would have if wouldn't have
said he would have kind of right because
he I remember he said that to me and I
say because he's like my son so he's in
my in my mind so I say yeah I'm like
that was ruling my language ah I guess
Joe Rogan I didn't know what your
background you know like I know I know
you did some Martian I thought he was
gonna think no but I he knew that
because a word get around the word gets
around that you have a very strong
spinning back-kick he saw is somewhere
somehow told him or he's seen it or
because he told me I remember he told me
then I was I yeah I'll do it when I go
to run with Freddie Roach and then and
then I couldn't believe it I called him
that the same night I said what was that
like this should be a nilly if he ever
fights managed this should be a lego you
can kill someone with this man is insane
man what's [ __ ] up is it almost feels
like a lie because it was so long ago it
was a different life I stopped fighting
I'm 50 years old I stopped fighting when
I was 21 so I haven't fought in forever
so it's just keep doing it in training
but I haven't done it so long so when I
tell someone that I can do it I'm like
this is that true magazine is it true
the how many people did you did you ever
light up someone with that particular yo
of me when I was 19 from a taekwondo
tournament making a guy fly through the
air yeah are you saying yeah oh my god
is he okay now he's yet I don't know
it is right here are you kidding me man
yeah so [ __ ] scratchy VHS video from
1980 so you realize you didn't even cut
him like you know we talk about
precision like there was like like your
technique is freaking pretty so powerful
like you got him where on the shoulder
on that no no I caught him on the body
it wasn't sure that you see it again
yeah that it's okay okay it's just his
arm but I start to put on that guy
always because it's very incredibly
powerful a guy would do the same thing
it him in the same spot it would
probably not get put away like there
okay see is he seeing like the impact it
goes right into his body and then I
extend and then when I extended he was I
was like kind of like oh yeah I see no
no that was that was perfect and he just
sailed through the air it's just it's a
crazy it's it's got so much power yeah
it's just a crazy technique and I was
raised in a Taekwondo school that came
from the old school Taekwondo before
tournaments see general che che Hong Yi
he trained he was the inventor of
Taekwondo the founder of Taekwondo and
he trained a small handful of elite
instructors and one of them was jaehun
Kim who was my instructor so my
Taekwondo background was the old school
Taekwondo before Olympic it was even in
a consideration and so everyone trained
for power it was a different thing
breaking yeah it was just it was you had
to be able to defend yourself in this
treat my instructors idea was if you
couldn't hurt someone with a kick like
why even practice it and these Taekwondo
guys in tournaments they were tapping
each other they were just moving way too
fast trying to score points and he hated
that [ __ ] he hated that [ __ ] and he felt
like you had to load up more there had
to be more power into those techniques
and it wasn't quite as fast as like the
the really quick style Olympic point
style Taekwondo yeah but that Olympic
point style wouldn't hurt anybody you
couldn't keep them off of you but that
thing is hard for me like I try to
practice your ways but I have a I don't
know if it's my hips or no it's just
it's just reps it's just repetition I
can go over here after we're done well
anyway now breaking hardware this gym
here I'll just give you a refresher yeah
a lot of it comes from the front leg
side kick nobody I know you know I go
back I went back to karate training
because I I've done more Thai but I was
coming from karate background and we've
done it straight not like you straight
then I'd moet I done I haven't done it
for a kid like back kick for a long time
because I don't really do that much and
more thigh now I went back to karate my
last fight and when I start to to redo
it
I've been taught again with the knee
knee down yeah but I like yours I like
the way you do it man is Indian grace
yeah then he has to be higher to get the
full power into it I just don't have
that same efficiency with it yeah it's
great it can be done you can learn that
efficient [ __ ] 100% it's freaking that's
better yeah but it comes from learning
first the right way to do the front leg
side kick see the front leg side kick
you develop that tomb that that knee
comes up and then boom it's all in
trusting that hip and popping it forward
and then once you develop the speed from
doing that then you do it with the turn
and then it's turn boom it's the same
thing it's that twist of the the hip and
the extension of the leg but then it's
also the turn first
so the turn first boom and then the
extension of the leg that's why that
power comes from it's all in a straight
line okay and then the 360 when the
right leg is forward and you step
forward and then throw yeah that was
that's like train there's the strongest
I ever seen Dutch it's crazy it's you're
running it some way you're not even in
your prime no nothin fifty [ __ ] yeah
but when I was 19 I could do it like a
laser beam that's the fact
yeah you know like in that video I mean
I just that's all I did though I mean
but from the time I was 15 so the time I
was 21 I didn't do [ __ ] I barely did any
homework and then pay attention in
school at all all I did was fight that's
all I did was night that's all I did
I just wanted to be in the Olympics I
wanted to be a Taekwondo champion Wow
yeah that's all I wanted to do but then
the problem was I started sparring with
kick boxers he's getting [ __ ] up
I realized that Taekwondo there's no
hands like the hand techniques were
useless and when I would be in a boxing
ring and I would be sparring with
someone they just get me in a corner and
start [ __ ] me up and I was like oh I
don't know how to do this
like I need to learn how to box and so I
realized Taekwondo in a lot of
situations is not effective it's not
useful yeah like I needed to learn how
to box first yeah so then I started
training that and then I started getting
try and train with more Thai guys
getting leg kicked I'm like ah [ __ ] now
this is because we were doing like above
the waist kickboxing yeah and then I saw
Rick Rufus when he fought that a Thai
fighter you know there's a really
important fight when Rick fought this
guy and I got just chopped his [ __ ]
legs around him like I saw that fight
however you put the same fight in in MMA
contests like I mean Rick Rufus beat the
[ __ ] out of him the first the first
first I think yeah you fuse a few
minutes yeah he killed a guy but the guy
used kind of the the rules to stand back
up then yeah you okay you put that in
the MMA context that's why it's striking
in MMA people say oh let's say
Mayweather goes into MMA I'll knock
everybody out if they stay standing I
don't agree with that at all man okay
kill ya even ladies not only the leg do
I think even the end that like Randy
quits or beat Victor bell for remember
with the how do you saw al you say that
in English like the the the boxing the
dirty boxing glitching is the very
difference even the distance the timing
would if just a small glove you know you
can change everything
sure then I spar I borrow a lot with
much better decorated pure wrestler than
me in MMA may I put them all down oh
yeah all of them not because I'm a
better wrestler is because my timing I
learned from karate how to close the gap
and karate but I use that I use a karate
for the takedown
some use Karate for blitzing and I
wonder boy yeah just depend on you use
your a tool you know what I mean what do
you think about Wonder Boy tell that's
this weekend oh I gonna watch this fight
I think two things can happen how long
are you gonna be in town for I leave on
Friday I got to go back on Friday
question yeah yeah fights on Sunday it's
here yeah no it's in England but it's
early ma it's race I'm gonna do a fight
companion we're gonna come in here and
watch it yeah I got I got I got that
boundless man that I wish I know I
seriously it's because I really got to
bounce but I had this we can have some
something important this weekend but man
I need to be a much other Saturday but
[ __ ] I would well do another type of her
life normally I watch fight with people
that doesn't know nothing about fight
it's [ __ ] fun we drink a couple beers
watch the fight my fight companion are
different than you know most of my
friends are not really fighters or like
normal guys geeks or whatever they think
they know but they don't know nothing
about fighting the way they are freaky
that I use and I try to be diplomatic
I'm sitting here and everybody's like do
this why didn't I and I used to try to
correct them I used to but I put so much
effort and energy that I just gave up on
one point I'm like the fight IRA would
live with wonder by people like I was
watching the fight say it's so boring I
do you just don't understand that with
Wonder Boy you go with one away and you
you you charge him like this you would
you know what I mean I think about is my
friend
and I want to talk about for there until
if you listen to this boy is my is my
friend but they just don't freaking get
it they don't understand they don't not
educated about the culture like a the
same thing on the floor or like and they
damn if you fight in the street that is
you know it's funny they're my boys when
I like them but a lot of them like
sometimes I listen not all of them but
some of them like knowledge they know
but they don't know man a lot of them
they think they know what they don't
know why I still love you guys but oh my
god sometimes it's hard you know
listen George let's wrap this up man
well thank you for coming here I really
appreciate it brother it's always great
to thank you man thank you
is that their real time it's real time
holy shoot that you say
via we did three hours oh my god are you
serious yeah you sure no I can't be the
real time or up in here man
dude that's insane I need to be today
Cantor let me check what are you gonna
go I go to the contender of Freddie
Roach what time's it say yeah I'm
checking better but you needed to train
with me and either I think I needed to
be there at 4:30 before you leave or
think I think it closed at 4:30
if you leave now you can be there by
4:30 yeah but I miss that freaking back
kick and instructional and which I
wanted I give you a week one real quick
[ __ ] let's [ __ ] do it you don't lie
enjoy your shirt no bye everybody
[Applause]
[Music]